[Musik]
nun ist sie zurück in London am Abend
ist der Sarg mit dem Leichnam von
Königin Elisabeth II im Buckingham
Palast angekommen
[Musik]
und schon jetzt campieren am Ufer der
Themse viele um der Queen ab dem
Nachmittag in Westminster Hall die
letzte Ehre zu erweisen
guten Tag meine Damen und Herren und
ganz herzlich willkommen zu diesem
zdf-spezial Trauer um Queen Elizabeth II
so heißt diese Sendung wir werden sie
bis 17 Uhr informieren über alles was an
diesem historischen Tag in der in London
der britischen Hauptstadt geschieht hier
ein Blick auf das bracht Boulevard the
mall der Weg der vom Buckingham Palast
hinter mir führt zu Horse Guards Parade
und dann auch zu Westminster Hall das
sind die wesentlichen Schauplätze des
heutigen Tages sie sehen dass ich schon
jetzt viele Menschen versammelt haben
hier am Viktoria Brunnen vor Buckingham
Palace es werden noch mehr werden und
wir wissen dass schon jetzt viele viele
tausende warten um dann auch persönlich
Abschied zu nehmen von der Queen die am
vergangenen Donnerstag verstorben ist
heute vor fünf Tagen nach 70 Jahren
Regentschaft im Alter von
99 Jahren in zwei Stunden beginnt dann
diese trauerprozession der Trauerzug
1522 deutscher Zeit wird die Queen dann
vom Palast hier über den Prachtboulevard
the mall hinüber gebracht zu Westminster
Hall und das ist schon auch symbolisch
vom Symbol für die britische Monarchie
geht ihre letzte Reise dann hinüber zu
dem Gebäude in dem seit Jahrhunderten
das britische Parlament untergebracht
ist
es werden viele tausende erwartet an
entlang dieser Route und dann auch in
den nächsten Tagen wo die Queen dann
vier Tage lang ihre sterblichen
Überreste aufgebahrt werden und wo
hunderttausende die Möglichkeit haben
werden dann auch persönlich von ihr
Abschied zu nehmen ich bin hier am
Kanada Gate vor Buckingham Palace nicht
allein sondern freue mich dass mich zwei
Kolleginnen begleiten die nächsten
Stunden das ist unsere
Expertin für die europäischen
Königshäuser Julia Melchior herzlich
willkommen und Diana Zimmermann die
langjährige Korrespondentin des ZDF hier
in London sie waren dabei Frau
Zimmermann als die Königin von
Schottland verabschiedet wurde und in
gewisser Weise auch sich selber im Tod
noch mal verabschiedet hat
gab es da Momente die sie überrascht
haben ist das sozusagen ein Vorgeschmack
gewesen auf das was uns heute erwartet
da gab es sehr viele überraschende das
erste war wohl dass als der Wagen durch
Schottland gebracht wurde wie viele
Menschen tatsächlich aus diesem dünn
besiedelten Schottland an die großen
Straßen gestrümmt sind auf denen die
Queen in ihrem Leichenwagen
transportiert wurde
Bauern haben ihre Traktoren Spalier
stehen lassen um sich von ihr zu
verabschieden und in Edinburgh war es
einfach unfassbar voll also die die
straßenborrows waren wirklich brechend
voll man kann kaum noch durch und sowas
erwarte ich jetzt hier auch nur
natürlich in noch größerer Form weil es
so viel mehr Londoner gibt als Schotten
das ist ja eine sehr sorgfältig geplante
trauer-zeremonie zehn Tage lang
Staatstrauer hier in London jeden Tags
eine ein großes Ereignis sozusagen was
ist die besondere Bedeutung dieses
fünften Tages Julia Melcher es ist ein
ganz symbolträchtiger und ganz
feierlicher Tag denn die Königin der
Briten wird heute den den qu den
Menschen übergeben sie hat ja diesem
Volk ihr Leben lang gedient und wird
jetzt den Menschen wird jetzt die
Möglichkeit gegeben im Symbol der
Demokratie Abschied zu nehmen von der
Königin und es ist auch ein tatsächlich
auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt heute dass
diese zehn Tage der Trauer auch
gestaltet werden also man kann nicht nur
darauf warten dass die Trauerfeier
stattfindet sondern es passiert halt als
auch was fangen jetzt auch Bilder an
meine Damen und Herren von dem was um
den Palast herum geschieht und wir haben
gesehen eben wie ein einzelnes Fahrzeug
dort hinein vor diese letzten Stunden
sind noch ein privater Moment sozusagen
für die königliche Familie die Königin
ist aufgebahrt in Buckingham Palace und
zugelassen ist nur ihr aller engster
Familienkreis der diesen Vormittag
sozusagen dann auch für seine seinen
privaten Abschied von der Königin von
der Mutter der Großmutter der
Urgroßmutter wird nutzen können
vielleicht sagen sie uns Frau Melcher
noch mal welche Rolle spielt im
öffentlichen Bewusstsein dieser
Buckingham Palace er ist ja
bekanntermaßen nicht der Lieblingsplatz
der Königin gewesen nee es ist auch sehr
ungewöhnlich also kein Monarch wählt
mehr freiwillig einen Ort mitten im
Zentrum und die Königin ist eigentlich
auch schon seit ihrem 80 Geburtstag nach
Winsor gezogen sie war nur von dienstags
bis donnerstags hier im Palast hat sich
mittwochs mit dem Premierminister
getroffen und immer wenn der Monarch
anwesend ist weht die Standarte auf dem
Palast und wir sehen auch gerade die
Standarte oben auf dem Buckingham Palast
weht auf voll Mast das ist die höchste
Fahne im flaggenprotokoll die die
Monarchie geht die endet nie also mit
dem Tod der Königin gab es in dem Moment
mit sofortiger Wirkung einen neuen König
und darum weht also diese Standarte
stets auf vollmast und der Monarch und
die Verstorbene Monarchin sind im
Buckingham Palast dem Symbol der
Monarchie also ein Ereignis auf vielen
Ebenen sagen wir mal das ist der
Abschied von der Königin viele sagen sie
war unser aller Großmutter so empfinden
viele Briten das es ist ein politischer
Machtübergang vom einen Staatsoberhaupt
auf das andere es ist Julia Melchior
aber auch ein besonderer Moment in der
Familiengeschichte der Winzers ja
natürlich also es ist natürlich der
Abschied von der von der geliebten
Granny für die jungen Leute es ist der
König musste Abschied nehmen von seiner
Mutter und das ist ja auch sehr
schwierig für diese Familie zu trauern
in aller Öffentlichkeit das bleibt ja
auch gar kein Moment der Trauer übrig
also König Charles und Königin Camilla
haben einen sehr sehr eng getaktetes
Programm jetzt gerade die haben die
ganzen Landesteile bereist und
sich von der Königin verabschiedet sich
Mahnwache gehalten also es ist ein ich
glaube es bleibt gar nicht viel Zeit zu
trauen und darum sind diese Momente der
Stille gestern Abend als im Buckingham
Palast der Sarg entgegengenommen worden
ist durch die Familie und dann natürlich
auch heute morgen der Abschied in dem
bowroom durch die königliche Familie wo
ich glaube auch die Kameras gar nicht
dabei sein dürfen
es mutet ja doch auch ein bisschen
befremdlich an Diana dass die Queen
sozusagen auch in ihren allerletzten
Momenten auch als tote noch so
öffentlich gezeigt wird also diese
Leichenwagen die wir in Schottland
gesehen haben die wir jetzt in London
gesehen haben mit den großen Fenstern
mit eigens eingebauten Scheinwerfern und
dann eben dieser Abschied für alle wie
erklärt sich das
zählt da nicht auch ein bisschen
Diskretion
das war ihre Entscheidung sie wollte das
gerne so sie wollte immer gesehen werden
sie hat immer gesagt sie muss gesehen
werden sonst glaubt niemand an Sie
interessant weil das natürlich so eine
religiöse Dimension da drin hat sie hat
selber über diese Form des Leichenwagens
mit entschieden und das sagt schon alles
diese gesamte zehn Tage die wir jetzt
sehen die wurden von ihr mit
orchestriert und sie hatte natürlich
wirklich ein sehr gutes Gespür dafür was
von ihr erwartet wurde bis zum Schluss
ja darüber sprechen wir noch mal dass da
auch ein Stück Politik drin steckt
vielleicht auch in der Entscheidung in
Balmoral zu leben und zu sterben und die
letzte Station in Schottland sozusagen
oder die erste Station der
Trauerfeierlichkeiten in Schottland dann
zu inszenieren kann man vielleicht schon
sagen darüber werden wir im Laufe der
Sendung auch noch sprechen lassen wir
aber meine Damen und Herren doch noch
mal ein bisschen genaueren Blick darauf
wie dieser heutige Tag ablaufen wird er
sagt der Königin das wissen wir aus
Einzelheiten des Protokolls wird auf
einer Lafette also sagen wir mal einem
militärischen Fahrgestell gezogen von
Pferden dann aus dem Buckingham Palast
herausgefahren werden und gegen 15 Uhr
22 so ist es geplant wird er den
Buckingham Palast verlassen er wird dann
gefolgt werden von König Charles und
anderen Mitgliedern der königlichen
Familie also hier Buckingham Palace der
borum ist übrigens der direkt hinter dem
Balkon auf dem die königliche Familie
sich so oft gezeigt hat wir stehen in
direkter Nachbarschaft zum Victoria
Brunnen auf dem Parkgelände das jetzt so
schön grün aussieht sind dutzende von
internationalen Fernsehgesellschaften
jetzt untergebracht vorbei am
Königlichen Saint James Park und dann
the mall entlang diese Prachtstraße war
übrigens auch die Residenz des damaligen
Prinzen auf Wales jetzt König Charles
des dritten legt Horst Guards Parade
also der eine diesem Platz der
Exerzierplatz der Könige white Hall das
Finanzzentrum das regierungszentrum
Verteidigungsministerium Download Tennis
um die Ecke und Westminster Hall das ist
eben diese berühmte gotische Halle vom
Ende des 11 jahrhunderts in der die
Queen dann aufgebahrt werden wird bis
nächsten Montag bis zu dem offiziellen
Staatsbegräbnis wo sich schon jetzt
Dutzende von Staatsoberhäuptern
gekröntenhäuptern aus aller Welt
angesagt haben auch das werden wir
natürlich übertragen wir haben unsere
korrespondentinnen und Korrespondenten
heute entlang der Route der geplanten
Route platziert und wollen Sie einmal
Fragen zunächst Andreas Stamm der of the
mall unterwegs ist Andreas es gab ja
ganz klare Anweisungen sozusagen für die
Menschen wetterfeste Kleidung die es
heute eigentlich gar nicht nötig weil
wir einen herrlichen Spätsommertag
erleben genug Proviant mitnehmen und am
Besten eine Powerbank fürs Handy also
ganz praktische Tipps wir erleben Sie
denn Andreas Stamm die Stimmung heute
ist das mehr Trauer oder wird hier auch
das Leben von Queen Elizabeth noch
einmal gefeiert und wird das noch mal
Revue passieren lassen
also absolut zweiteres mit jedem den man
hier spricht sagt natürlich es war
Trauer und Schock in diesen ersten
Minuten als die Meldung kam aber die ist
ein wenig gewissen es ist mittlerweile
eben eine Feier es ist eine fröhliche
Stimmung eben das Leben der Queen dass
sie sich aufgeopfert hat für ihre
Bevölkerung ihren Dienst an den Menschen
es werden sich Anekdoten erzählt auch
teilweise persönliche denn die
Statistiker haben ja mal ausgerechnet
dass bei den Zehntausenden öffentlichen
Auftritten der Queen ja statistisch
jeder dritte Brite irgendwo in Ihrer
Nähe gestanden haben muss und da müssen
wir sehr viel gelacht natürlich wenn der
Sarg hier vorbeikommt in ungefähr einer
Stunde anderthalb Stunden dann wird das
ein anderer Moment sein dann wird es ein
Moment der Trauer sein aber jetzt geht
es erstmal darum sie zu feiern und es
ist sehr fröhlich ausgelassen und ja
eben ihr Leben für die Briten und das
wollen die Menschen hier begehen deshalb
sind sie zusammengekommen zahlreich es
füllt sich und das wird wahrscheinlich
dann erst auch in den nächsten halben
Stunde mal deutlich Anschwellen der
Strom von Menschen
Andreas Stamm nun wurde auch die
britische Hauptstadt London in der
Vergangenheit von Terroranschlägen
getroffen die Queen war zur Stelle hat
die Opfer dann auch besucht im
Krankenhaus wie ist denn die
Sicherheitssituation heute gibt es hier
Ängste in dieser Hinsicht
natürlich macht man sich bei einem
solchen Mega-Ereignis sorgen keine Frage
und für ja Sicherheitsexperten ist das
natürlich ein kleiner Albtraum das muss
man sagen es gibt überhaupt keine
Möglichkeit für Taschenkontrolle die
königliche Familie besteht ja quasi
darauf sehr nah zu sein ohne jeglichen
Schutz ja nur Meter entfernt von von
Zehntausenden das ist natürlich für für
Menschen die sich mit Sicherheit
beschäftigen ein Albtraum also für den
amerikanischen Präsidenten wäre das
glaube ich undenkbar insofern ist dann
natürlich Sorge aber am Ende des Tages
sind 10.000 Polizisten unterwegs die
britischen Behörden gelten als ja wenn
ich die Spezialisten für diese Art crowd
control also die Massen kontrollieren
und ja sie sicher durch ein solches
Ereignis zu geleiten 1500 Soldaten
stehen bereit sollte wirklich irgendwie
da noch Bedarf sein also ich glaube das
ist das sicherste was man bieten kann
aber natürlich gegen Einzeltäter zum
Beispiel ist es sehr schwierig
vorzugehen aber im Moment hat man hier
das Gefühl und ich glaube alle fühlen
sich gut aufgehoben und sicher
ja danke einstweilen Andreas Stamm der
amerikanische Präsident ist in der Tat
dann auch auf der Gästeliste am nächsten
Montag und er ist der Einzige dem es
dann erlaubt sein wird mit seinem
eigenen Auto der bekannten großen
amerikanischen Staatskarosse sich hier
zu bewegen sozusagen in seinem eigenen
sicherheitsgefährt während alle anderen
Staatsgäste auf Bundespräsident
Steinmeier hat sich dann angesagt für
nächsten Montag in einem Busreisen
müssen um zu den verschiedenen
trauerstätten dann zu kommen das wird
nächsten Montag sein aber bleiben wir
heute und gehen dann zu Theo Koll
unserem Kollegen der an Westminster Hall
steht und dort beobachtet wie die
Stimmung ist Theo es sind sehr viele
Zahlen unterwegs manche sagen es sind 10
tausende manche sagen es sind
hunderttausende manche sagen es werden
am Ende Millionen sein die sich von der
Queen persönlich verabschieden werden
wie ist es bei ihnen wie ist es im
unmittelbaren Umfeld des Platzes Queen
heute Abend dann aufgebaut wird
also hier sind die wartenden ja noch
nicht angekommen weil sie auf der
anderen Seite der Themse sich anstellen
müssen Schlange stehen ist ja im Prinzip
für die Briten eigentlich keine
wirkliche Herausforderung aber dieses
Mal ist es besonders denn am
Montagnachmittag haben sich schon die
ersten Menschen angestellt damit sie
sicher gehen dass sie es wirklich
schaffen hier westminsterholt zu
erreichen und sich von ihrer Königin zu
verabschieden die Schätzungen sind
350 bis 400.000 Menschen die die Chance
haben werden sich von der Königin in
Westminster Hall zu verabschieden aber
die Zahlen in der Tat variieren
natürlich wie viel Interesse wirklich
bestehen 750.000 vielleicht mehr als
eine Million aber die Menschen haben die
Chance genutzt seit Montagnachmittag
sich hier schon anzustellen es gibt
Berichte über Veteranen die die ganze
Nacht gestanden haben damit sich die
Uniform nicht zerknittert also das ist
eine sehr britische Form des Respekts
zeigen bei der
ja und das was wir hören ist dass man
quasi rund um die Uhr mindestens 23
Stunden dann auch am Sack der Queen wird
vorbei definieren können ab heute
Nachmittag 17.30 18 Uhr so sind die
bisherigen Planung aber Theo sie
beobachten ja nachdem sie viele Jahre
Korrespondent in London waren jetzt vor
allem die deutsche Politik warum ist
denn ausgerechnet Queen Elizabeth den
Deutschen so ans Herz gewachsen haben
sie dafür eine Erklärung
sie hat uns die Hand gereicht nach dem
Krieg elisabeth war das ja eigentlich
gar nicht
in den Schoß gelegt dass sie ein
positives Verhältnis zu Deutschland
entwickeln würde sie war zu fünf
Staatsbesuchen in Deutschland und vielen
privaten weiteren Besuchen aber sie ist
65 schon zum Kriegsgegner zum ehemaligen
Gefahren man muss dazu bedenken dass
Buckingham Palace ihr zu Hause während
des Zweiten Weltkriegs bombardiert wurde
von deutschen als die Eltern zu Hause
waren ihre Mutter hat einen geliebten
Bruder Fergus im Ersten Weltkrieg
verloren also die Mutter war nicht
wirklich in großer Zuneigung zu den
deutschen geprägt und dennoch hat
Elisabeth diesen Schritt gemacht und hat
die Hand ausgestreckt nach Deutschland
hat bewusst in positives Verhältnis auch
zum Land aufgebaut und vielleicht spielt
es auch ein wenig eine Rolle das
natürlich das britische Königshaus
deutsche Wurzeln hat und wir auch keine
Monarchie haben also vielleicht gibt es
da auch eine gewisse kleine Sehnsucht
die durch die erfüllt wird
ja kann man wohl sagen viele sagen ja
sie ist ein bisschen auch unsere Königin
Prinz meine Damen und Herren die
Live-Bilder die wir zwischendurch zeigen
zeigen natürlich London sozusagen von
der glanzseite eines Stadt die
einerseits viele Royale Traditionen auch
was die Architektur angeht zu bieten hat
und auf der anderen Seite eben auch
viele moderne ultra moderne Gebäude
Zentrum der Finanzindustrie und da
werden wir dann schon fast auch beim
neuen König Charles dem dritten der sie
als Prinz auf Wales ja manchmal auch
gegen moderne Architektur gewandt hat
darüber mehr dann auch im Laufe der
Sendung bleiben wir aber zunächst mal
noch bei der Frage nach dem Verhältnis
zwischen Queen Elizabeth II und den
deutschen bei mir ist Carina Urbach
Historiker hier an der University of
London ist das noch spürbar in der
windsor-familie das ist da deutsche
Wurzeln gibt und wie ist eigentlich die
Beziehung zur deutschen Verwandtschaft
ja also wir haben natürlich als deutsche
unseren besten Mann nach England
geschickt das war damals Prinz Albert
der Ehemann von Queen Victoria aber wir
haben natürlich dann auch im 20
Jahrhundert das Problem gehabt dass sehr
viele Deutsche Verwandte in die NSDAP
eintraten und das ist jetzt Gott sei
Dank überwunden mit neuen Generationen
und deswegen wird auch die Familie baden
und die Hessens und die Coburgs bei
dieser Beerdigung vertreten sein also
die kommen Victoria erinnert und mancher
sagt ja Elisabeth II ist eigentlich
steht in einer Reihe mit den großen
britischen Königin Elisabeth der ersten
mit ihrem Zeitalter Victoria die auch
mehr als 60 Jahre regiert hat jetzt die
Queen 70 Jahre
welche wie würden sie das Einordnen hat
Elisabeth II wirklich ein eigenes
Zeitalter kreiert naja sie hatte
natürlich nicht so viel Einfluss wie
Queen Victor ja also Queen Victoria hat
immer noch politisch mitgemischt und bei
Elisabeth II wissen wir das einfach
nicht wir haben ihr Nachlass nicht
gesehen wir werden das erst in 100
Jahren herausfinden wenn ihre
Korrespondenzen freigegeben werden aber
wir wissen sie war auch ein Politik
Junkie genau wie Queen Victoria sie hat
sich sehr interessiert
hintergrundsgespräche geführt und
natürlich hat sie soft power ausgeübt
als Diplomatin das vertiefen wir auch
noch mal jede Woche ein Gespräch mit 15
wechselnden premierministerinnen und
Premierminister es ist niemals was davon
nach außen getrunken aber vorobacht was
ich Sie noch fragen wollte warum
Westminster Hall also die britische
Monarchie präsentiert sich heute sehr
traditionell aber hier kommt ein neuer
Akzent rein oder absolut also es ist
wirklich so dass die Monarchie
verstanden hat sie muss sich immer
wieder neu erfinden um relevant zu
bleiben und die Idee mit Westminster
Hall ist erst 100 Jahre alt also Queen
bevor ihr zum Beispiel wollte private
Beerdigungen sie hat keine Aufbahrung
gewollt und man hat das ein bisschen
geklaut also man hat gesehen dass bei
William gladston die Beerdigung mit
einer Aufbahrung ein riesen populärer
Erfolg war und hat dann 1911 auch
angefangen wir machen auch eine
Aufbahrung und das war dann bei Edward
den siebten ja und wenn man so will ist
es selbst im Tod noch eine Methode sich
dem Volk zu zeigen und den Menschen nah
zu sein beobachten wir sprechen gleich
weiter die Stimmung im Netz meine Damen
und Herren das kommt ja heute dazu dass
eben nicht nur hunderttausende
vielleicht Millionen von Menschen hier
in London ganz persönlich diesen
Trauerfeierlichkeiten folgen sondern
überall auf der Welt wird natürlich auch
im Netz das was in den letzten Tagen
passiert ist kommentiert und auch
kritisiert und diese Stimmung beobachtet
für uns Christina von Ungarn sternberg
was beobachten sie da wie welche
Stimmung gegenüber Elisabeth II spüren
Sie wenn Sie britische aber auch
deutsche Accounts anschauen
ja Peter frei wir begleiten ja diese
Sendung auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
über die ZDF heute App über Facebook
über Youtube über den Instagram Account
von ZDF Royal und sehen dann natürlich
sehr sehr viele Kommentare und wir sehen
sehr viel Anteilnahme zum Beispiel
schreibt ein eine Userin namens Anja
obslop ein Geschenk so lange seine
Eltern zu haben dennoch ist der Verlust
immer ein schmerzlicher Einschnitt weil
etwas unwiderruflich zu Ende geht Gottes
Segen dem neuen König der Regierung und
dem ganzen britischen Volk für einen
echten Neubeginn ein anderer User Dirk
RDM schreibt wenn ich den Sarg sehe
wirkt es immer noch wie ein schlechter
Traum
Barbara wolko schreibt über Youtube ruhe
in Frieden jetzt ist sie wieder bei
ihrem Mann und Mario Padawan 71 sagte
über Youtube schön dass ihr es live
zeigt also es gibt viel Freude darüber
dass die berichter so umfassend ist man
muss aber auch fairerweise sagen es gibt
viel Kritik daran und viele Userinnen
und User sagen das Thema Monarchie das
Thema Königshaus in Großbritannien diese
Trauer Feierlichkeiten neben viel zu
viel Raum in der Berichterstattung ein
das vertiefen wir gleich noch mal Frau
von Ungarn Sternberg aber wir sehen ja
die Bilder mit den Blumensträußen die
hier und ich habe es in den letzten
Tagen auch persönlich gesehen an sehr
sehr vielen Stellen rund um den
Buckingham Palace und überall dort wo
eben der Sarg vorbeigefahren wurde
niedergelegt wurde es sind wirklich
tausende zehntausende die auf diese Art
und Weise der Könige noch mal ihren
Respekt bezeugen das ist die eine Seite
die andere Seite ist die Kritik an
welchen Punkten macht sich das Fest
vergangenen Standard
ja da gibt es einen ganz großen
Themenkomplex vor allem hier in
Großbritannien nämlich das Thema
Meinungsfreiheit unter dem Hashtag Not
myking denn es hat in den vergangenen
Tagen immer wieder vereinzelt Proteste
gegeben auch in Schottland auch hier in
London eine Frau wurde dort vor dem
Parlament von der Polizei abgeführt weil
sie einen Plakat in die Höhe gehalten
hat wo Hashtag not myking drauf stand
also Monarchie feindliche Kommentare
wurden hier sehr schnell tatsächlich von
der Straße geräumt muss man sagen das
hat zu einer großen Diskussion im Netz
geführt und da schreibt eine deutsche
Userin auf Twitter dazu Frau alpakasan
die englische Monarchie hat aber auch
ein ziemlich fragiles Gerüst wenn Sie
ein paar Pappschilder mit not my King
nicht aushalten kann das ist also ein
großes Thema ein anderes sehr großes
Thema was auch viele Userinnen und User
unter unseren Posts auch auf Instagram
zum Beispiel bewegt ist das Thema
Kolonialismus da wird viel mehr
berichter Richtung gefordert auch über
die Rolle des britischen Königshauses
was das commonwears angeht was die
Geschichte angeht hier wird viel mehr
Berichterstattung und Aufarbeitung
gefordert aber auch das wird ja noch ein
Thema in der Sendung sein
ja dazu empfehle ich Ihnen ein
entsprechenden Post auf der
instagram-seite von ZDF heute sehr
informativ die Briten und ihr Empire was
bedeutet das heute wie wird das Thema
Kolonialismus hier diskutiert sie können
auch natürlich ihre Einschätzung und
ihre Kommentare dort hinterlassen Diana
Zimmermann wenn man die britischen
Medien beobachtet da ist schon auffällig
dass es eben nicht nur um Trauer nicht
nur um erbietung geht sondern dass die
kritischen Aspekte sozusagen genauso zu
Wort kommen zum Beispiel der dass diese
zehntägige Trauer dann auch manche
Bereiche dieses Staates in den letzten
Tagen und in den kommenden Tagen
lahmlegen wird ja ist richtig so finde
ich dass die Berichterstattung kritisch
ist darum sollten wir uns alle immer
bemühen und das ist natürlich auch hier
so obwohl tatsächlich die BBC schon sehr
staatstragend trauernd momentan ist
tatsächlich befindet sich Großbritannien
kurz vor einer gigantischen
Wirtschaftskrise und allein die Tatsache
dass am Montag wieder ein Feiertag ist
ist natürlich ein weiterer Schlag für
die Wirtschaft den viele Leute als sehr
kritisch betrachten und finden das seit
übertrieben und unangemessen heute
morgen im Frühstücksfernsehen wurde
einem jungen Mann viel Raum gegeben der
darüber klagte dass jetzt die Behandlung
seines Krebskranken Vaters sozusagen
aufgeschoben wird weil auch in den
Krankenhäusern weniger Menschen arbeiten
wegen dieser Trauerphase ja das ist ein
anderes wahnsinnig großes Thema hier 6,7
Millionen Briten warten auf Behandlung
das ist vor allen Dingen durch Corona
Geschehen natürlich wo die Krankenhäuser
sehr stark in Anspruch genommen fahren
vor allen Dingen in der ersten Welle
hier das Gesundheitssystem ist ohnehin
wirklich schlecht ausgestattet und total
überlastet und das kommt jetzt eben nach
oben drauf also die Menschen wegen ab
was passiert hier was für ein bremporium
wird um die clean gemacht und was
braucht dieses Land eigentlich wirklich
momentan also ein bisschen zugespitzt
konnte man sagen der königliche Glanz
der jetzt noch mal aufscheint seit
letzten Donnerstag und heute einen
ersten Höhepunkt hier erfährt in London
der entspricht nicht immer der der
sozialen Lager und auch der
wirtschaftlichen Lage von Großbritannien
im Gegenteil kann man sagen dass der
königliche Glanz sehr vieles überdeckt
von dem was darunter liegt und was in
vielen Fällen eben wirklich ziemlich
schlecht läuft in diesem Land und in den
letzten Jahren zunehmend schlecht läuft
das ist ganz klar es geht ja auch darum
Julia Melchior welche Akzeptanz der neue
König dann finden wird die Umfragewerte
sind sprunghaft in die Höhe gegangen in
den letzten Tagen ja er galt ja
irgendwie lange auch als eine tragische
Figur weil er im Schatten seiner Mutter
stand dann dieses diese schmutzige
Liebesgeschichte damals mit damals mit
Camilla und er galt halt auch immer als
der öko-spinner der also vor 40 Jahren
sich für Umweltthemen stark hat und das
sind eigentlich gerade diese Attribute
sind welche die also unheimlich zu
Format verholfen haben in den letzten
Jahren die Beständigkeit in der Liebe zu
seiner Camilla er hat sein Leben lang
diese eine Frau geliebt der Langmut im
warten auf den Thron und der frühe Kampf
mit Leidenschaft mit viel Leidenschaft
und Überzeugung für Themen die heute von
höchstem Interesse sind also König
Charles III ist überhaupt keine
tragische Figur mehr sondern er ist
sicherlich jemand im fortgeschrittenen
Alter der jetzt sagen wir so den
Karrieresprung macht wo andere schon im
Ruhestand sind aber auch mit guten
Themen junge Leute für sich begeistern
konnte und das ist sehr sehr wichtig
denn es sind nur 30 Prozent der unter
24-Jährigen die überhaupt ihre
Zustimmung für die Monarchie aussprechen
und da kommt dann also auch natürlich
die nächste Generation ins Spiel Prinz
William und Prinzessin kate ist jetzt
die Prinzessin von Wales der Prinz of
Wales und die Prinzessin von Wales die
spielen also sicherlich eine sehr sehr
große Rolle in der Regentschaft von
König Charles dem dritten und wir werden
Sie dann auch gleich sehen dann der Sarg
aus Buckingham Palace herausgeführt wird
aber die spannende Frage für die Zukunft
wird natürlich auch sein wie viel der
Prinz von seinen politischen
Überzeugungen hier dann noch mit
einbringen wird und können wird bei
einer
momentchen falls sehr konservativen
Regierung hier wird es zu Spannungen
kommen oder wird der zu dem sehr
neutralen Kurs zurückkehren den seine
Mutter gepflegt hat Themen die wir in
den nächsten Stunden auch noch
besprechen werden schauen wir aber zum
Schluss noch mal 40 Kilometer westlich
von London nach Winzer dort ist unsere
Kollegin Anne Pröhl dort wo die
königliche Familie ihren Hauptwohnsitz
hat jedenfalls in den letzten Jahren hat
auch bieneves vor allem dort gelebt dort
wird sie am Montag beigesetzt werden
eine was bedeutet die Queen für dieses
kleine hübsche Städtchen an der
Peripherie von London
ist ja eine kleine Stadt 25.000
Einwohner aber fast alle Einwohner sind
in irgendeiner Weise auch mit dem
Schloss verbunden viele Arbeiten dort
und für die ist eben nicht nur ihr
Staatsoberhaupt die Queen die
Ehrenbürgerin ihrer Stadt gestorben
sondern auch eine Nachbarin in vielen
Schaufenstern der Geschäfte sieht man
Fotos der Queen auch Worte der
Anteilnahme des Beileids für die Familie
und auch hier an einem der palastore
kann man Blumen niederlegen und viele
Menschen machen das wir haben in den
letzten Tagen eine junges Paar aus
Coventry getroffen dass seine fünf
Wochen alte Tochter mitgebracht hat das
heißt es kommen auch Menschen aus dem
ganzen Land und auch aus allen
Altersklassen wir haben Menschen gesehen
hochbetagte die von ihren Angehörigen im
Rollstuhl geschoben werden nachmittags
kommen die Schulkinder die Blumen
niederlegen aber auch Trauerkarten und
da ist dann darauf zu lesen danke für
eine Menschen die bis zuletzt ihre
Pflicht erfüllt hat das ist hier also
ein wirklich kollektives Abschied nehmen
Dankeschön Anne Brühl nach Winzer wir
werden am Ende der Sendung noch einmal
darüber sprechen wie dann die
Feierlichkeiten auch am Montag
vonstatten gehen werden ja die Kameras
zeigen uns immer wieder die Kameras der
britischen Kollegen Bilder von diesem
Prachtboulevard der den Buckingham
Palace auf der einen Seite verbindet mit
dem politischen Zentrum von London hier
der Victoria Brunner und das ist schon
besonders eindrucksvoll hinter dem Grün
des sein James Park dann diese moderne
Kulisse es ist ja auch ein Symbol dafür
wie sehr sich unter der Regentschaft von
Königin Elisabeth dieses Land verändert
hat das Land das zwar den Zweiten
Weltkrieg gewonnen hat nach dem London
bombardiert worden war von den Nazis das
aber in den 50er Jahren dann in
Rückstand geraten ist wirtschaftlich
gesehen von der Bundesrepublik aber doch
in den letzten Jahren einen
spektakulären Aufschwung genommen hat
die Schwester der Königin sprach ja
davon 1953 an das Licht der
Krönungszeremonie für Elisabeth II wie
ein Phönix aus der Asche sein London und
sei Großbritannien nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg wieder auferstanden wir sehen
dass sich hier schon die militärischen
regimenta vorbereiten das ist alles seit
Jahren minutiös geplant man kann
wirklich sagen dass hier jeder Schritt
in Protokollen festgelegt worden sind
die in den Schubladen der Amtsstuben
gelegen haben das wird heute uns seit
fünf Tagen realisiert und dann am
nächsten Montag sozusagen zum krönenden
Abschluss kommen wenn
Königin Elisabeth dann auch beigesetzt
wird nach einem feierlichen Gottesdienst
dann in Westminster Abbey aber wir
wollen einmal hören mit welchen Gefühlen
die Menschen heute hierher gekommen sind
nach London können wir mal rein
ich glaube es war der französische
Ministerpräsident der sagte wir alle
haben eine Königin verloren aber die
Briten haben ihre Königin verloren die
ganze Welt kennt sie als die Queen
viele Staaten haben Könige und
Königinnen wenn man deren Bürger fragt
wer die sind wissen das nicht immer alle
unsere Queen kennt jeder
wollte einfach dass sie da ist man hat
sich wohl gefühlt mit ihr
haben wir eine richtig gute Stelle hier
erwischt besser als wir dachten das wird
sehr emotional heute wir sind froh dass
wir hergekommen sind
sie war eine solche Stütze für das Land
unglaublich und wunderbar im Umgang mit
den Menschen die plomatisch und höflich
bei der königlichen Ausstellung in Wales
getroffen und die Queen sagte stellen
Sie mir nach ich sagte natürlich nicht
aber sie war so freundlich sie war
einfach vornehmen und liebenswürdig
ja Diana Zimmermann vornehmen und
liebenswürdig hat die Dame eben gesagt
und das vielmehr auch im britischen
Fernsehen auf da kamen Menschen zu Wort
und und eine Dame über 70 sagte mir hat
die Queen die Hand gegeben als ich acht
Jahre alt war ich habe das nie vergessen
seitdem liebe ich sie also es scheint
wirklich einfach ein sehr persönliches
Verhältnis hier zu geben ein sehr
persönliches Verhältnis und dieses
vornehmen und liebenswürdig das ist ja
auch ein bisschen so wie man selber gern
wäre ich glaube das ist das ist auch so
ein bisschen der Abschied der das jetzt
so schwer macht das ist so ein besonders
gutes Bild von einer
herausragenden Britin ist mein
verabschiedet sich nicht nur von der
Monarchin sondern von einem eben
besonders vornehmen und liebenswürdigen
Menschen das heißt man hat irgendwie
auch das Beste von dem was man von sich
selbst erwartet was man von seiner
Nation erwartet von seiner Kultur ein
Stück weit auf sie projiziert und den
Rest
bei den Rest spricht man auch mal
aber sie war so eine Projektionsfläche
das macht
sie ein weil sie ja keine Meinung jemals
von sich gehabt zu irgendetwas das heißt
alle Kosten irgendetwas in sich hinein
projizieren das gab zu Zeiten des brexit
gab es da immer wieder Diskussionen ist
sie für den brexit oder gegen den brexit
und dann hieß es die habe mal gesagt sie
findet das eine ganz gute Idee dann
tauchte sie zur queensuite und einem
blauen Kleid und einem blauen Hut mit
gelben Blümchen aufsah aus wie die
eu-fahne daraufhin sagt alle sie ist
natürlich gegen den brexit also sie bot
einfach viel Fläche für Projektion und
aber auch für Diskussionen und das ist
glaube ich was was man wenn man das
kritisiert wie stark die Briten auf die
Monarchie blicken und auf diese
Königsfamilie nicht vergessen sollte das
eben auch ganz viele Diskussionen die
rund um diese Familie passieren wirklich
relativ notwendige Diskussionen sind
Julia hat schon angesprochen mit Charles
und der Ökologie william ist ganz stark
bei psychischer Gesundheit das sind
Themen die hier normalerweise gerade in
der Familie nicht diskutiert wurden und
die sie nach vorne bringen und insofern
spielt das ist das auch ganz gut dass da
so viel hinein projiziert werden kann es
geht also auch heute auch wenn man so
will Frau Mercure um ein Stück
Positionierung der winsors für die
Zukunft also wie wird man aufgestellt
sein mit welchen Personen mit welchen
Themen und da fällt auf dass William
nicht alleine ist sondern dass sein
Bruder ganz offenbar nach einem
jahrelang Zerwürfnis hier wieder eine
Rolle spielen ja aber er spielt jetzt
keine Rolle für das Königshaus dieser
dieser
Ausscheiden von Prinz Harry und Herzogin
Meghan aus dem Königshaus das ist ein
endgültiger Schritt gewesen da gibt es
auch kein Zurück mehr aber viel mehr
sind jetzt also die Augen auch darauf
gerichtet wie dieses familienzerwürfnis
gekittet werden kann denn es war ja
schon sehr heftig in den Wochen vor dem
Tod der Queen gab es also auch die
Behauptung in einem Interview von von
Meghan Harry habe seinen Vater verloren
und das hat also damals auch Prinz
Charles hart ins Mark getroffen und er
hat jetzt neulich in seiner Ansprache am
Tag als der König wurde abends an der
Ansprache an die Nation darüber
gesprochen
dass er dienen werde und welche Rolle
der Prinz auf Wales spielen werde sein
Sohn und von seiner tiefen Liebe zu
Harry und Meghan also der Vater hat dem
Sohn die Hand gereicht und auch bei der
Proklamation am vergangenen Samstag hat
er also die Urkunde unterschrieben und
dieses Tintenfass war ein Geschenk von
den beiden Söhnen an den Vater also
natürlich wenn die viele Augen darauf
gerichtet aber es ist nicht von Relevanz
das ist wichtig für die Familie aber von
Relevanz wie sich dieses Königshaus
positioniert sind Prinz William und
Prinzessin Kate natürlich die Königin
Königin Camilla dürfen wir immer nicht
vergessen der Bruder Prinz Edward und
seine Frau Sophie und ganz wichtige
Rolle spielt also auch Prinzessin Andy
Princess Royal die er jetzt auch in den
letzten Tagen beim Abschied der Königin
immer dabei war also der Kreis
derjenigen der zur eigentlichen
königlichen Firma gehört der ist ein
bisschen kleiner geworden
der ist kleiner geworden das war auch
ein bewusstes Zutun von Prinz Charles
noch in der Regentschaft seiner Mutter
die Familie zu verschlanken auf die
wesentlichen Player nicht mehr diese
Bild von der barocken Königsfamilie von
dem werden wir uns verabschieden müssen
also am Geburtstag der Queen wenn Sie
alle hier auf dem Buckingham Palast
standen diese Bilder wird es so nicht
mehr geben es sind weniger
Leistungsträger die aber dann natürlich
mehr Arbeit machen müssen Prinz Andrew
wurde auf drang von Prinz Charles damals
aus der Familie oder vor einigen Monaten
aus der Königsfamilie ausgeschieden
Prinz Harry ist von sich ausgegangen
also es sind jetzt vor allen Dingen es
wird ein Kleeblatt sein sicherlich es
ist keine One-Man-Show mehr König
Charles sondern die Königin und das
thronfolger-party eine große Rolle
spielen werden alles folgt an diesem
heutigen Tag ja einen strengen Protokoll
die wir eben gesagt haben das ist schon
seit Jahren festgelegt die dieser
heutige Tag ablaufen wird aber gibt es
eigentlich Informationen darüber ob die
Queen sich irgendetwas sozusagen
besonderes gewünscht hat das wissen wir
ja vom Begräbnis ihres Mannes Prinz
Philip vor einem Jahr der hat bestimmte
Wünsche geäußert hat sie das auch weiß
man darüber was also mir persönlich ist
es nicht bekannt das einzige was ich
weiß dass die Königin zusammen noch mit
dem Premierminister entschieden hatte
dass Montag einen Feiertag wird der
jetzt nicht bindend ist die Leute können
auch im Homeoffice arbeiten aber es wird
einfach nur versucht so ein bisschen
Ruhe reinzubringen hier denn es werden
ja doch wirklich Millionen Menschen
erwartet die sich in Bewegung setzen um
hier nach London zu kommen es werden
alle Staatsgäste nach London kommen der
Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten alle
gekrönten Häupter also es wird
sicherlich an Gäste Aufgebot geben am
Montag von einer Dimension die es so in
der Geschichte noch nicht gegeben hat
und auch ehrlich gesagt nie wieder geben
wird also insofern ist das sehr wichtig
dass dieser Montag sehr strukturiert
auch unter allen sehr
Sicherheitsaspekten stattfindet ja
schauen wir noch mal vielleicht auch auf
die Bilder die uns das
deutsche Fernsehen liefert die Busse die
hier hinter uns durchfahren Sie sehen ja
zwischen Diana und mir da bemüht sich
gerade ein Auto noch mal hier um
Straßenreinigung ich habe beobachtet
dass in den wunderbaren Park und
Gartenanlagen noch vor 20 Minuten eine
Gärtnerin dabei war für Ordnung zu
suchen und vielleicht was
rauszunehmen was dort nicht hingehört
also
sehr liebevoll und bis zum Schluss wird
hier dafür gesorgt dass kündigen
Elisabeth einen würdigen Abschluss
bekommt hier in ihrer Hauptstadt in
London wieder Tag bisher verlaufen ist
das zeigt uns Isabel Thymian
tausende nahmen gestern Abschied in der
saintials-kathedrale von Edinburgh es
ist still in dem mächtigen Gotteshaus
auf dem Sarg die königliche Standarte
und Blumenschmuck mit den
Lieblingsblumen der Queen
[Musik]
vor der Kathedrale reihen sich die
Menschen ein zum Abschiedsgruß
sie war ein so großer Teil im Leben von
jedem und ich bin froh hier zu sein und
ihr unseren Respekt zeigen zu können
und emotional ich bin wirklich glücklich
dass ich die Chance hatte in die
Kathedrale zu gehen und ihr Respekt zu
zollen und mich zu verabschieden ich bin
vom Commonwealth indischer Herkunft
aufgewachsen in Kenia und jetzt
glücklich in Großbritannien zu leben
unser Vater hat uns immer erzählt dass
er vorher noch nie gesehen hat wie eine
Frau über Männer regiert und er schwor
dass er wenn er Mädchen bekommen würde
würde er die so erziehen also verdanke
ich meine Erziehung dieser großen Lady
[Musik]
idge am Abend vorher hatten die Kinder
der Queen die Totenwache gehalten
Charles an Andrew und Edward in stillem
Gedenken an ihrer Mutter
und dann die Reise durch das Land
gesäumt von tausenden Menschen am
Straßenrand wird der Sarg zum Flughafen
gefahren
[Musik]
am Abend erreicht der Konvoi dann
Buckingham Palace
in London warten die Menschen schon seit
Tagen auf ihre Queen viele haben sich
decken Tee und warme Kleidung
mitgebracht
ich denke für jemanden der 70 Jahre
seines Lebens diesem Land gewidmet hat
sind zwei Nächte warten nicht so viel
oder
ich habe mir einen Stuhl mitgebracht das
war wichtig denn meine Beine sind nicht
mehr so gut und ich kann nicht mehr so
gut lange stehen
ich trinke nicht so viel Wasser die
Schlangen vor den Toiletten sind jetzt
schon lang
ich komme aus Belfast ich war vor ein
paar Tagen schon da um Blumen
herzubringen jetzt haben wir uns den
Platz hier gesichert ich will ihr meinen
Respekt erweisen
hunderttausende Menschen aus allen
Teilen der Welt und des Commonwealth
sind gekommen Abschied von einer Königin
die eine ganze Ära prägte
ja eine ganze Ära prägte wir sehen hier
wie einzelne Fahrzeuge in den Buckingham
Palast hineinfahren dürfen es ist die
aller Ängste Familie und die engsten
Familienangehörigen die in diesen
Stunden in Buckingham Palace sein dürfen
es wird dort auch eine kleine religiöse
Zeremonie geben ein abschiedsgebet wird
gesprochen werden in dem Festsaal in dem
die Familie häufig genug sich getroffen
hat um zu feiern nach Hochzeiten zum
Beispiel heute nimmt sie dort Abschied
von Königin Elisabeth der zweiten Theo
Koll ist an der Westminster Hall also am
Ziel des heutigen
trauerzugs
warum wird die Queen ausgerechnet dort
aufgebaut
und die Entscheidung ist Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts gefallen 1897 wurde hier
zum ersten Mal William Gladstone
staatlich aufgebahrt und seitdem ist es
der Ort an dem Royals und auch
bedeutende Politiker sehr wenige
Churchill war einer von denen aufgebaut
wurden also das ist ein Ort wo sich im
Grunde Parlament und Monarchie treffen
der die Westminster Hall ist ja ein Teil
vom
Parlamentsgebäude aber ist eigentlich
der der Royale teil und auch der älteste
Teil der ja zurückgeht aufs 11
jahrhundert und ist im Grunde eine eine
wunderbare Melange ein Symbol für die
Verbindung von Monarchie und Parlament
und damit auch von Volk insofern war das
sehr folgerichtig dass auch die Königin
jetzt hier staatlich aufgebaut wird wie
übrigens auch schon ihre Mutter 2002
Queen Mum also das ist ein perfekter Ort
eine Symbiose im Grunde für diese Trauer
vielleicht weil sie das auch damals als
Korrespondent mitverfolgt haben
die Queen hatte 2002 den Abschied von
ihrer hundertjährigen Mutter zu
verkraften
1997 dieses katastrophale Jahr für die
Monarchie anlässlich des Todes von Diana
und auch damals tagelange
Trauerfeierlichkeiten ein Zug durch die
Stadt der dem was wir heute erleben
werden ja durchaus ähnlich war
welchen welche unterschiedliche
Temperatur so will ich dass man dann in
der Gefühlslage spüren sie heute
es ist deutlich unterschiedlich also
natürlich hat es viele
Ähnlichkeiten man verabschiedet sich im
Grunde von einem sehr fernen und
zugleich sehr vertrauten
Familienmitglied alle
Diana und auch natürlich Queen Elizabeth
waren den Menschen extrem vertraut sie
waren einfach sie sind in allen Facetten
des Lebens vorhanden gewesen Prinzessin
Diana natürlich durch ihre enorme
mediale Präsenz durch die Krisen aber
die Stimmung damals war eine völlig
andere das war im Grunde an nationale
hysteriegrenzend es waren viel mehr
Menschen auf der Straße es war natürlich
auch ein junger Mensch der tragisch
verunglückt war sie war
im Grunde die Betrogene
geschiedene Ehefrau die auch von den
Windsors gesnappt wurde die eigentlich
ein anderes
monarchieverständnis auch gezeigt hat
anderes und heute verabschiedet man sich
von einer
im besten Sinne von einer Großmutter von
einem Geländer das das ganze eigene
Leben begleitet hat bei mir habe ich
eine der führenden Kommentatoren des
Landes en mcafey vom economis und ich
würde sie gerne auch mit dieser Frage
nach vorne
belästigen nämlich was im Grunde an
King Charles entschuldigungs passiert
immer noch an King Charles an
Herausforderungen jetzt wartet wie muss
er die Monarchie neu adaptieren
Theo du hast ja eben von einem Monarchie
Verständnis gesprochen und ich glaube
das muss immer neu gestaltet werden und
dieser Tagen diese Tagen und diese Zeit
in London und im ganzen Land ist von
Übergang und auch ein neuer Anfang und
Prinz Charles King Charles dritte ja
steht jetzt für diesen Neuanfang oder er
muss selber entscheiden wir kennen ihn
sehr gut er ist unser vertraut er ist
auch über 70 Jahre alt das heißt es kein
junger Mensch der diesen wichtigen Job
annimmt aber er ist sein eigener Mensch
er hat das schon klar gemacht der ist
kein Selbstläufer in dem Sinne und er
muss es ein bisschen neu gestalten
natürlich mit Würde und mit Erinnerungen
an seine Mutter die so beliebt war wo
steht das Land ja offensichtlich immer
nach vorne schaut nach dieser Woche der
Trauer durchaus vor schweren Krisen die
Entscheidung des brexit hat die
Wirtschaft geschädigt wir haben die
Folgen der jetzigen Wirtschaftskrise was
kommt da auf das Land zu welches Land
findet vor ihr findet vor ein Land
glaube ich zwischen Angst und Hoffnung
Angst und die Ängste die auch nicht nur
in Großbritannien wir wissen wir sind ja
ernstzunehmender Zeiten also es ist
wirtschaftlich endet nie in der
geopolitiker was mit Russland und
Ukraine jetzt Leuchte und auch wo kein
Ende abzusehen ist aber ich glaube für
Prinz Charles es ist nicht so im Sinne
von eine politische
Einrichtung er hat ja manchmal den Hof
dass er sich gerne hier und da einmischt
aber er wird sich glaube ich und seine
Zeit und vor allem seine erster Zeit als
Thronfolge als eine beschwichtige
beschwichtige Rolle verstehen er weiß
dass dieser Spannungen innerhalb des
Landes aber auch mit dem Kontinent
vorhanden sind und er wird versuchen da
eine positive Rolle zu nehmen und es
wird sehr interessant wie macht der denn
das hier weil er hat ja aber immer sehr
Konsequenzen mit seinen Auftreten mit
seinen Interessen grüner Prinz
vielleicht auch ein grüne König
schon aus Öko so ein bisschen
abgestempelt das ist heutzutage sieht
das schon besser aus aber ich würde
sagen der hat ja schon einen neuen
Anfang oder muss selber entscheiden und
welchen tun und die Prioritäten die
ersetzen wird absolut fasziniert schauen
wir noch mal auf zum Schluss auf die
Priorität Richtung Deutschland Richtung
Europa wir wissen ja dass die Königin
gutes Verhältnis zu Deutschland hatte
eher selber ist auch schon über 30 Mal
in Deutschland gewesen was erwarten sie
von seinem Verhältnis zur Europäischen
Union zu Deutschland ich glaube das
könnte schon ein positiver man kann ja
nicht von einer neu anfangen mit der
Euro versprechen wir müssen ja wir sind
ja immer schwieriger Verwandte sagen wir
mal so und vor allem nach dem brexit hat
das sind das wurde dann hervorgehoben
aber ich glaube er wird vielleicht ein
bisschen öfter aufs Kontinent fahren und
nach Deutschland und würde dann
versuchen das Verhältnis neu zu
gestalten und Frische zu geben denn die
Verhältnisse die Beziehungen die sind ja
hier wir sind gewinnt das auch am Montag
sehen da kommen die großen ehemaligen
Familien aus deutschen die sehr intensiv
mit der Monarchie hier verflochten sind
aus Hessen aus Coburg und das ist nur
natürlich das ist jetzt Geschichte aber
es spielt nach wie vor ein Roller und
vor allem in der Familie wird das immer
sehr wohlgemerkt dass dies Verhältnisse
Deutschland wichtig ist in der Zeit als
die Königin elfte wurde sie konnte nicht
mehr so oft Reisen ist es vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr im Hintergrund ich wäre
vielleicht überrascht wenn Charles das
nicht irgendwie versucht neu zu
gestalten ein bisschen mehr Energie und
dynamische zu gestalten
vielen Dank für diese Informationen und
damit zurück vom Parlamentsgebäude zum
Buckingham Palace und Peter frei
ja vielen Dank Theo dass die Beziehung
zwischen Queen Elizabeth II und den
deutschen und Deutschland werden wir
gleich noch mal vertiefen aber zunächst
will ich noch mal meinen Gast hier
fragen Carina Urbach die
deutsch-britische Historikerin so ein
betagter Thronfolger 73 Jahre ist
Charles Alter ist das eigentlich eine
Neuigkeit in der britischen Monarchie
oder hat es schon gegeben also es hatte
schon gegeben diese späten Thronfolger
und er statistisch gesehen sieht es
nicht so gut für ihn aus also Georg IV
wurde
1820 dann Thronfolger und hat nur zehn
Jahre gehabt und Edward der siebte hat
neun Jahre gehabt es ist natürlich so
dass diese Thronfolge schon sehr bekannt
waren in der englischen Öffentlichkeit
und meistens negativ also besonders
Georg der vierte galt als verschwende
und auch Edward der siebte als Lebemann
also dieser dieser Vorlauf hat natürlich
ihre ganze Mannschaft dann überschattet
da muss jemand einen ganz neuen Job
antreten zu einer Zeit wo dann die
meisten von uns schon in Rente gegangen
sind ja genau das ist glaube ich das
große Problem dass er natürlich
vielleicht nicht ganz so gesund ist wie
seine Mutter also die ob er diese
Langlebigkeit hat also man wird man
hofft dass man wünscht es ihm aber die
Anzeichen sind eher dass das natürlich
für ihn sehr sehr anstrengend ist
vielleicht noch mal ein ganz sachlicher
Blick auf das Zeremoniell des heutigen
Tages diese öffentliche Aufbahrung von
vier Tagen in der bedeutendsten
bedeutendsten Gebäude das eben auch für
Demokratie steht in Großbritannien
Westminster Hall wem gebührt diese Ehre
wem wird diese Ehre zu teil wir haben
eben schon gehört nicht nur
gekräuterhäupter sondern auch Churchill
wer trifft diese Entscheidung ja also
natürlich streichen bekommen immer ein
Staatsbegräbnis und vielleicht sollte
man sagen das zahlt jetzt auch der
englische Steuerzahler also das wird
natürlich vom Steuerzahler bezahlt aber
sonst ist es in der Entscheidung des
Parlaments also der Regierung man hat
Churchill natürlich ein Staatsbegräbnis
gegeben und das wird dann auch vom
Steuerzahler finanziert aber sonst sind
Royale Beerdigungen natürlich nicht
automatisch staatsbegräbnisse sondern
nur
Staatsbegräbnis einer Regierenden
Monarchin Monarchen das Vaters von
Königin Elisabeth George VI liegt 70
Jahre zurück genau liegt 70 Jahre zurück
und man vergisst natürlich ich auch sehr
viel also das Protokoll muss ich dann
neu formulieren man muss neue Elemente
reinbringen und es war natürlich auch
eine sehr militärische Beerdigung weil
er sich ja auch als Soldat sah und ich
glaube dass die Queen sich auch als
Tochter eines Soldaten sieht genau wie
Queen Victoria das immer betont hat ich
bin die Tochter eines Soldaten und
deswegen wird es militärische Element
hier sehr sehr große Rolle spielen wir
werden dann auch sehen wie Queen an
wahrscheinlich in Uniform heute Auftritt
was auch die Verbindung zeigt zwischen
dem Königshaus und dem Militär und
übrigens dieses Staatsbegräbnis für King
George den 6 wurde natürlich noch nicht
vom Fernsehen übertragen anders als die
königliche Krönung von Elisabeth 1953
genau ja und es ist ja auch interessant
1953 starb dann auch Queen Mary also die
die Frau die Großmutter von Elisabeth II
und bei Queen Mary gab es auch eine
Aufbahrung und das war ein Flop also die
verlief nicht besonders gut weil sehr
wenig Leute kommen weil alle die Krönung
dann natürlich sich darauf freuten und
das sehen wollten also so eine
Aufbahrung das muss man auch gut timen
die darf nicht zu lang laufen denn man
will ja Massen zeigen und nicht so ein
paar Leute die da durchmarschieren auch
eine bewerbungsprobe wenn man so will
für die Monarchie jedenfalls haben wir
gelernt meine Damen und Herren das was
wir heute erleben werden nach 70 Jahren
wird das erste Staatsbegräbnis für eine
so lange sieben Jahrzehnte amtierende
Monarchen sein
70 Jahre hat wenn man so will die Welt
darauf warten müssen 70 Jahre einer
Regierungszeit die umspannend war von
der Nachkriegszeit Rationierung von
Teebeuteln noch
1952/53 hin zu einem Großbritannien dass
ich als globale Nation versteht
verobacht vielleicht noch das ist die
schwierigste Frage zum Schluss als wird
als als was wird Queen Elizabeth in die
Geschichtsbücher eingehen
ich glaube sie sie war die die beste
Klassensprecherin die man sich
vorstellen kann sie wird als ja als
Expertin für soft diplomacy in die
britische Geschichtsbücher eingehen sie
hat sehr viel für ihr Land geleistet
definitiv eine Klassensprecherin die
manchmal gar nicht sprechen durfte und
auch vieles das Schweigen sozusagen klar
gemacht hat
Queen Elizabeth und die deutschen das
Stichwort viel schon schauen wir uns mal
gemeinsam und etwas genauer an
[Musik]
es ist einer ihrer schwierigsten
Staatsbesuche 1965 betritt die Queen zum
ersten Mal deutschen Boden 20 Jahre nach
dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs dem Ende
des nazi-regims
man hat den Besucher seine Geste der
Versöhnung empfunden weil England
insgesamt und in diesem Fall hat er der
Besuch auch noch eine starke persönliche
Note
11 Tage reist Elisabeth quer durch
Westdeutschland egal ob Bonn Hamburg
oder München
Jubelarien für die Königin die so viel
mehr mit Deutschland verbindet ihre
Ahnen gehen zurück auf das 18
Jahrhundert als die Hannoveraner dafür
sorgten dass der britische Thron einen
guten Händen blieb und kontinuierlich
besetzt war das waren deutsche
Kurfürsten danach kamen die Familie
ihres Urgroßvaters von sachsen-koven
roter wieder eine deutsche Familie und
wohin so heißen sie eigentlich erst seit
1917 also mitten im Ersten Weltkrieg der
König damals Georg der fünfte den Namen
wechselte er war im Krieg mit
Deutschland und wollte keinen deutschen
Namen für die Familie haben
in Berlin der Frontstaat des Kalten
Kriegs steht 1965 seit vier Jahren die
Mauer
Augenblick der Reise war der Besuch der
Mauer dieses verhassten Symbols der
Teilung Deutschlands und der Welt
hunderttausende Berliner hoffen auf ein
Bekenntnis der Alliierten Schutzmacht
[Musik]
and people
ihr erster Staatsbesuch sendet ein
starkes Signal die Zeit der
deutsch-britischen versöhnung ist
angebrochen
ein Bekenntnis ganz unter dem Eindruck
des Kalten Kriegs in dessen Zeichen ihr
zweiter Staatsbesuch 1978 steht die
Sowjetunion protestiert gegen die
Anwesenheit des Bundeskanzlers in Berlin
es ist die Hochzeit des
Ost-West-Konflikts
meine Regierung und mein Volk stehen an
ihrer Seite meine in Berlin
stationierten Soldaten verkörpern die
Verpflichtung Großbritanniens ihre
Freiheit so lange wie nötig zu
verteidigen bis die Wunden der Spaltung
in Europa und in ihrer Stadt geheilt
werden können
bei ihrem dritten staatbesuch ist aus
dem Wunsch Realität geworden
1992 besucht die Queen das
wiedervereinigte Deutschland der Gang
durch Brandenburger Tor Symbol der
Freundschaft und des Danks für die
britische Unterstützung während der
Teilung wir im Vereinigten Königreich
haben uns mit ihnen gefreut so wie ich
das heute getan habe als ich durchs
offene Brandenburger Tor ging dass die
Freiheit nun in der ganzen Stadt und im
geeinten Deutschland herrscht
doch es brechen auch alte Wunden auf
Proteste in Dresden manche fordern eine
Entschuldigung für die britischen
Bombenangriffe Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs
die Antwort Elisabeth feierlich weil sie
das neue Kuppelkreuz der Frauenkirche
ein finanziert mit Spenden der Queen und
aus ganz Großbritannien
der vierte Staatsbesuch 2004 es ist eine
neue Zeit Absperrungen Angst vor einem
Terroranschlag der Irakkrieg droht
Europa zu spalten
[Musik]
wir müssen erkennen wie wertvoll der
Frieden ist den wir in Europa seit 1945
aufgebaut haben
jemand meiner Generation kann dies kaum
genug betonen
einer der Grundsteine dieses Friedens
ist die Partnerschaft unserer beiden
Länder in der NATO und der Europäischen
Union
Großbritannien Deutschland und Europa
ihr fünfter und letzter Staatsbesuch
2015 steht im Zeichen einer kriselnden
Partnerschaft wenige Monate später
stimmen die Briten über den EU-Austritt
ab
wir haben den Kontinent von seiner
schlechtesten aber auch von seiner
besten Seite kennengelernt die Spaltung
Europas kann gefährlich sein
die Briten wählen den brexit einmal mehr
verändert sich das deutsch-politische
Verhältnis Elisabeth II stand für eine
Ära in der aus Feinden Freunde wurden
die Briten in Deutschland einen Partner
fanden und sie ihre Liebe fand in
Philipp Mount Betten geboren als Philip
von Schleswig-Holstein Sonderburg
Glücksburg ihrem Gemahl aus deutschem
Hause
[Musik]
fünf Staatsbesuche in sieben Jahrzehnten
ihrer Regentschaft der ersten 1965 war
historisch weil zu diesem Zeitpunkt mehr
als 50 Jahre kein britisches
Staatsoberhaupt Deutschland besucht
hatte eine große Geste eine Geste auch
der Versöhnung zwischen Großbritannien
und Deutschland es ist meine Damen und
Herren 14 Uhr wir melden uns hier vom
Buckingham Palace am Kanada Gate wir
erwarten dass in einer guten Stunde der
Sarg mit den sterblichen Überresten von
Elisabeth II dann von Ihrem Londoner
Wohnsitz dem Buckingham Palace über die
Mall übergeführt wird zum
Regierungsviertel hin zu Westminster
Hall wo er dann für vier Tage aufgebahrt
wird und die Menschen ihre persönliche
Referenz erweisen können der
Verstorbenen Königin die am letzten
Donnerstag in valmorell in Schottland
aus dem Leben geschieden ist mit 96
Jahren und nach 70 Jahren Regentschaft
sie sehen hier die Prachtstraße the mall
sechs spurig für solche Anlässe auch
gebaut der rote Straßenbelag das ist
kein Zufall er soll am besten an die
roten Teppiche erinnern mit dem vor
allem ausländische Gäste hier im
Buckingham Palace begrüßt werden heute
haben sich 10.000 versammelt auch an
dieser Strecke um noch einen Blick zu
erhaschen auf den Sarg der Könige der
dort gleich
vorbeifahren wird bleiben wir einen
Moment bitte die Anna Zimmermann noch
beim Verhältnis der Queen zu den
deutschen dass sie
wenige Jahre nach Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs der ja auch London verwüstet
hat sie selber hat fliehen müssen mit
ihrer Schwester nach Windsor Castle hat
sich in Sicherheit gebracht sozusagen
das evakuiert worden wie viele andere
britische Kinder einen deutschen
geheiratet hat das spricht schon für
sagen wir mal Eigensinn oder das war
finde ich der bemerkenswerteste Moment
von Eigensinn von Elisabeth II nicht so
unrecht wird ja ständig hier ihre
Pflichterfüllung betont und dass sie nie
einen she never put the food wrong das
heißt sie hat nie irgendwas Falsches
getan aber in den Augen ihrer Familie
war das schon sehr umstritten dass sie
diesen deutschen Prinzen noch dazu einen
verarmten deutschen Prinzen unbedingt
heiraten wollte dessen vier Schwestern
alle mit Nazi-Größen verheiratet waren
also das war tatsächlich sehr umstritten
aber sie hat ja schon sehr früh
beschlossen dass sie diesen Mann haben
will und keinen anderen und hat das auch
durchgezogen auch das ähnelt ein
bisschen vielen Victoria der Mann ja
auch nicht nur von der man nicht nur
weiß dass sie einen deutschen geheiratet
hat Albert sondern den man auch nachsagt
eine glückliche Ehe geführt sein und 40
Jahre lang schwarztrug nach seinem Tod
vielleicht Julia Melchior auch von ihrer
Seite
Prinz Philip der Mann der immer hinter
der Queen hergehen musste
war er nur eine Figur fürs Protokoll
oder war mehr
auch sehr viel mehr also die Queen hat
es an ihrem ich glaube zur goldenen
Hochzeit gesagt in einer Rede hier was
my strence and stay mein halt mein meine
stütze ich glaube dass der ganze Erfolg
auch warum wir die Königin jetzt in
diesen Tagen so
verabschieden und sie also auch so
gewürdigt ein großer Erfolgsfaktor war
dabei Prinz Philip also er hat ihr
natürlich also erstmal auch den ganzen
Rücken frei gehalten also ist ja
eigentlich ein sehr modernes Paar
gewesen wenn man das so will sie hatte
den Top Job erhielt ihr den Rücken frei
er hat also alle Verwaltungsfragen
geregelt auch was die ganzen Besitzungen
betrifft er hat diesen königlichen
Haushalt auch geführt also darf man sich
jetzt nicht so vorstellen mit dieser
hauswirtschaftsrolle sondern also
vielmehr dann also im Personalfragen und
so und er war für sie auch ein sehr
wichtiger Ansprechpartner also es gibt
ja niemanden auch bei diesem ganzen
Personal im Palast und da sind ja auch
sehr leitende Führungspersönlichkeiten
die da arbeiten die ihr die Meinung
sagen können ist es nicht aber Prinz
Philip das ist doch jemand der mir auch
mal einfach mal den Kopf waschen konnte
und sagen konnte so nicht oder ich habe
jetzt hier ich sitze am Steuer ich habe
das sagen und das war eine ganz
wichtiges Korrektiv für sie noch mal
über die deutschen Wurzeln dieser
Familie sprechen dann fällt ja auch auf
dass man ein bisschen Kosmetik betrieben
hat und dafür gesorgt hat dass die Namen
nicht mehr ganz so deutsch Klang
sonderbox Sonderburg Glücksburg Sachsen
Coburg und guter und Hannover also das
sind diese Familien die da alle
reinspielen aber das war nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg war es also nicht mehr passend
Sachsen Coburg und Gotha zu heißen und
1917 entschied dann also der damalige
König Georg der fünfte das Haus
umzubenennen nach dem Lieblingsschloss
der Winzers und aus Battenberg wurde
mountbacken im Fall
Theo call werden wir doch noch ein
bisschen politischer die Queen und die
Deutschen die würden sie das politische
Erbe sozusagen die politische Leistung
beurteilen die Queen Elizabeth für das
deutsch-britische Verhältnis erbracht
hat
ich glaube das war wirklich diese Brücke
die sie gebaut hat sehr sichtbar mit dem
ersten frühen Staatsbesuch schon und
dann immer wieder und das wird glaube
ich auch von Charles weitergeführt hat
das gar nicht in dem im Grunde im
öffentlichen Schatten der Königin so
beachtet dass Charles schon über 30 Mal
in Deutschland war also er ist jemand
der übrigens relativ gut deutsch spricht
ich habe das schon mehrfach erlebt bei
reden die er in Deutschland gehalten hat
wo er auch durchaus schwierige Themen
auf Deutsch
angesprochen hat und und die Königin
selber hat durch diese Staatsbesuche
einfach sehr sehr klar gemacht diese
Brücke muss gebaut werden wir müssen dem
ehemaligen Kriegsgegner die Hand reichen
und das war dann auch für viele Briten
die natürlich hier geprägt sind von den
Erfahrungen zweier Weltkriege es gibt
immer noch durchaus Vorbehalte gegen
Deutschland
die sich einfach tradieren aber wenn
dann die oberste Repräsentantin wenn im
Grunde die Chefin von allen sagt nein
wir müssen jetzt den deutschen die Hand
geben und ich fahre dahin und ich fahre
da gerne hin und ich bleibe da auch
länger dann war das im Grunde der
königliche des königliche Siegel dafür
dass sich das deutsch-britische
Verhältnis besser muss und dass man dem
alten Kriegsgegner die Hand gibt
Theo wir sehen jetzt gerade die Bilder
unserer britischen Kollegen und sind im
Regierungsviertel gewesen weitrall dort
wird der sag auch vorbeigebracht werden
und jetzt an Blick auf den Westminster
complex da gibt es die Kathedrale oder
gibt es Parlamentsgebäude da gibt's
Westminster Hall ich will sie noch mal
ansprechen weil sie ja die Gelegenheit
hatten der königlichen Familie auch
selbst zu begegnen
welche Eindrücke haben sie dort gewonnen
wie nahbar sind die Windsors wenn man
ihn nahe kommt
das ist hochinteressant weil es sehr
dialektisch ist sie geben einem das
Gefühl dass sie sehr nah sind und
gleichzeitig sind sie natürlich
unerreichbar fern
ein kleines Beispiel ich war bei einem
Abendessen eingeladen mit Prinz Edward
also dem jüngsten Sohn der Königin in
ganz kleinem Kreis und vor dem Beginn
des Abendessens ging er dann von einem
zum anderen und unterhielt sich mit
jedem ungefähr eine Minute und man hatte
das Gefühl dass man am nächsten Morgen
am liebsten mit ihm noch mal einen
Kaffee trinken gehen würde und dann
drehte er sich weiter und sprach mit dem
nächsten wieder eine Minute also diese
Fähigkeit im Grunde den Menschen das
Gefühl zu geben dass sie sich sehr
interessieren aber keine eigene Meinung
äußern und einbringen das war ja auch
eine eine ganz große Fähigkeit die die
Queen hatte das sie eigentlich
zugehört hat aufgenommen hat sich
interessiert hat aber selber
wenig oder keine Position bezogen hat
also das war für mich sehr eindrucksvoll
und schafft eine emotionale Nähe das
haben wir auch ganz viele die am
Straßenrand sind wenn die Königin
irgendwo vorbei definiert genau dieses
empfunden das verbunden mit einem
persönlichen Strahlen ich bin ja einmal
als Korrespondent hier wurde man dann
irgendwann ja auch vorgestellt es gab
diese berühmten Gartenpartys im Sommer
und die Kollegen haben sich dann einen
Spaß gemacht die ganzen Fotos die es gab
man wird ja der Königin dann förmlich
vorgestellt das ist ja so und so und
dann gibt es einen kurzen Austausch und
während dieser Vorstellung werden Fotos
gemacht und die Kollegen haben dann bei
mir auf den Fotos gesehen dass ich die
Haken zusammengeschlagen habe und ich
bin wirklich kein militärischer Mensch
aber sie hat einen diese zarte kleine
Frau hat eine eine solche Aura zentral
das ist dazu führte dass ich meinen
Respekt so erweisen wollte
offensichtlich instinktiv
ja ich habe mir erzählen lassen dass bei
ihrem letzten Staatsbesuch in Berlin ist
dann nach dem offiziellen Bankett auch
die Möglichkeit gab für 30 Auserwählte
Gäste noch ein bisschen mit ihr zusammen
zu stehen und es gab nur eine Anweisung
des Protokolls und die hieß you have
forty five seconds also eine dreiviertel
Minute um zu einem intensiven Austausch
zu kommen mit der Queen für 30 Leute
aber nach einer halben Stunde war dann
das auch vorbei und alle waren zufrieden
also das ist so ein bisschen ihr
Geheimnis dass sie bei ich glaube auf in
mehr als 110 Ländern bei ihren
Staatsbesuchen offenbar immer wieder
angewandt hat
hat ja auch jeder das Gefühl hier im
Königreich die Königin persönlich zu
kennen also das ist ja auch die große
Gabe ich meine über diese 70 Jahre
hinweg und ja auch als schon als kleines
Mädchen war sie ja sehr präsent und ist
also die zeigt sich oder sie schickt
halt auch ihre Familie raus und jeder
hat in im Königreich ob er jetzt nun für
die Monarchie ist oder nicht hat das
Gefühl eine Beziehung zu der königlichen
Familie zu haben und das ist ja auch das
Besondere was diese Faszination
Königshaus ausmacht dass man diese
Menschen begleitet von der Wiege bis zur
Ware und
Elisabeth als Enkelkind von dem
damaligen König George der fünfte sie
war ein absoluter Kinderstar und ich
glaube das macht also auch diese
emotionale Bindung aus der Menschen
jetzt beim Abschied von der Königin ich
habe gerade noch mal geschaut 117
Ländern in 70 Jahren und 1,6 Milliarden
Kilometer gereist ob ihr das noch mal
jemand nachmachen kann wir werden sehen
wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit auch
dort nach fragen wo es keinen
offiziellen Empfang gibt wo es keine
Anweisung des Protokolls gibt sondern wo
sich einfach ganz normale Londoner
versammelt haben und an diesem Tag um an
diesem Tag dabei zu sein bei Andreas
Stamm
mit Derby aus Brighton aus dem
wunderschönen Brighton das ist doch
deutlich fröhlicher und und festlicher
als man gedacht hat weniger Trauer ist
really morestive Mo happy and less grief
than I expected
in have one
with in Twitter
erklärt es ist natürlich es war schon
emotional als sie am Palast vorbei sind
da steht ja der sagt noch aber man hat
eben jetzt auch schon so viel gesehen
man hat gesehen wie die Menschen sich in
Schottland verabschiedet haben und das
ist natürlich schon ein gewisser das
nimmt den Trauer und den Schock ein
bisschen weg
also ihr seid zum Urlaub in den Urlaub
fahren aber wir haben gesagt heute
wollen wir noch mal hier sein warum ist
das
es geht eben und da geht's glaube ich
allen hier so es geht darum dieser
Königin Respekt zu zollen sie werden in
Urlaub sein aber auch da live dabei sein
eben dann mit einem Cocktail am Pool
sitzen oder am Meer das hätte die Queen
sicherlich sehr gefreut also der Sinn
für Humor ist nicht verloren gegangen
und es gibt sogar Leute die sich hier
vor uns verstecken weil sie heute ja
nicht auf ihrem Arbeitsplatz bei Ihrem
Arbeitgeber erschienen sind die dürfen
auf keinen Fall Filmen also ist eine
tolle Stimmung hier und natürlich warten
alle auf den Sarg und das wird dann ein
trauriger Moment aber momentan ist es
sehr sehr feierlich hier entlang der
Strecke
ja Andreas stammen vielen Dank für diese
Schilderungen und die letzten Tage
folgten einem strengen Ritual übrigens
nicht nur was den Umgang mit der
Verstorbenen Königen angeht sondern auch
der neue König Charles III der ja in
diesem Moment sozusagen sein Amt
angetreten ist als Königin Elisabeth II
verstorben ist auch er hatte ein sehr
klar Vorhalt definiertes Pensum zur
absolvieren er hatte Pflichten er musste
die trauerkundgebungen in Schottland
wahrnehmen zum Beispiel und auch in
Nordirland wohin er gestern gereist ist
Andreas Weise berichtet
Montagvormittag London Charles der
dritte begibt sich auf eine Reise durch
einen Vereinigtes Königreich das er gut
kennt dass ihn aber nun neu kennenlernen
will als König
in Edinburgh der schottischen Hauptstadt
ist es still trotz der tausenden von
Menschen die die Royal milesäumen einen
Blick auf den Sarg der Queen und den
neuen König erhaschen wollen Charles
Prinzessin Andy Prinzen Andrew und
Edward alle vier Kinder der Queen ein
Bild das ist so lange nicht gab Chris
Jackson fotografiert die Royals seit 20
Jahren ist auch jetzt nah am König
ich denke dass das auch eine neue
Erfahrung für ihn ist gerade heute als
er das erste Mal Gott save the king
gehört hat das muss merkwürdig für ihn
gewesen sein der sagt dann aufgebahrt in
der Singles Kathedrale wo die Menschen
Abschied von der Queen nehmen können
für den neuen König steht nun ein Besuch
im schottischen Parlament an hier
regiert die Scottish National Party die
eine politische Trennung von London will
doch die Politik hat erstmal Pause
in einer sich immer verändernden und oft
turbulenten Welt bei ihrem Majestät eine
konstante sie war der Anker unserer
Nationen
ich gehe nun an meinen neuen Aufgaben
mit Dankbarkeit für alles was Schottland
mir gegeben hat immer das Wohlergehen
des Landes und seiner Menschen im Blick
dann halten die vier Königinnen Kinder
bis in den Abend Totenwache am Sarg ihre
Mutter
Dienstagmorgen der König kommt nach
Nordirland
freundlicher Empfang für Charles den
dritten an der königlichen Residenz
hillsbüro Castle vor den Toren von
Belfast
to dedicated die Königin hat geschworen
sich dem Land und seiner Leute zu widmen
und die Prinzipien der konstitutionellen
Regierung beizubehalten jetzt mit diesem
leuchtenden Beispiel und mit Gottes
Hilfe nehme ich meinen neuen Pflichten
an
dass er diese Prinzipien betont für
viele in Nordirland ein Problem und auch
wenn Michelle O'Neill von der Irish
republikanischen Shin Fan dem König
sichtbar herzlich ihr Beileid ausspricht
in den Vierteln Belfasts die sie
unterstützen glaubt man nicht dass er
die Macht hat mitreden für mehr
Aussöhnung zu sorgen
er kann aus eigenem Antrieb keine Rede
halten die Rede wird quasi von der
aktuellen Regierung geschrieben weil er
keine verfassungs- oder Regierungsgewalt
hat er macht das was ihm gesagt wird der
andere Teil der Nordiren ist mehr als
glücklich den neuen König zu begrüßen es
sind vor allem Unionisten die um jeden
Preis Teil des Vereinigten Königreichs
bleibt
am Trauergottesdienst für Queen
Elizabeth nehmen auch Irlands Präsident
und Ministerpräsident sowie die neue
britische Premierministerin teil und
kurz danach ist Charles der dritte
wieder unterwegs Richtung London
und aus Belfast ist uns jetzt mein
Kollege Andreas Weise zugeschaltet der
diesen außergewöhnlichen Tag gestern
mitverfolgt hat als eben Charles III
sich dort präsentiert hat und man kann
schon sagen Andreas das neben Schottland
wo die Unabhängigkeit ja trotz des
gescheiterten Referendums immer noch in
der Luft liegt eben auch Nordirland
eines der schwierigen Territorien ist
eine schwierige Nation aus Londoner
Sicht
wie ist Charles dort empfangen worden
wenn man von den Tausenden absieht die
auf den Straßen waren und ihre Sympathie
ausgedrückt haben was für eine Aufgabe
liegt dort vor ihnen
ja es liegt eine immenseaufgabe vor
König Charles denn es kommt darauf an
gerade diesen Landesteil im Prinzip im
Vereinigten Königreich zu halten
als er gestern hier ankam war es so dass
vor allen Dingen hier in der Stadt
dort wo er sozusagen offiziell aus der
Kirche herausgekommen ist das waren
ausgesuchte Leute die dort standen die
wurden vorher ausgewählt die wurden nach
warenhand verlesen aber am Rand
sammelten sich dann die die wirklich
glücklich waren dass der König da war
das waren die Unionisten die unbedingt
im Vereinigten Königreich haben wollen
und die waren sehr sehr glücklich die
waren wirklich die waren happy also wir
standen mittendrin haben von dort
berichtet und das war wirklich
interessant zu sehen wie sehr sie sich
auf diesen neuen König gefreut haben
denn er ist ihre Symbolfigur hier in
Nordirland und die anderen die die gerne
aus dem Vereinigten Königreich raus und
zur Republik Irland wollen die haben
sich dafür nicht interessiert die sind
einfach nur zu Hause geblieben
nun muss man sagen Andreas Weise Charles
III und die königliche Familie ist ja
von diesem Nordirland Konflikt auch
persönlich betroffen seit dem Attentat
auf laut mount-batten dem Onkel dem
Charles sich immer sehr sehr verbunden
gefühlt hat erst bei einem
Bombenanschlag der EA ums Leben gekommen
spürt man von diesem Schlag noch etwas
wie wie geht Charles damit um spielt es
eine Rolle wenn er sich in Nordirland
auffällt
es ist ja so dass seit dem
Karfreitagsabkommen von 1998 im Prinzip
mehr oder weniger Ruhe eingekehrt ist
das heißt aber nicht dass unter dieser
dünnen Decke die über den ganzen
Konflikten liegt oder beziehungsweise
unter dieser dünnen Decke es nicht immer
noch brodelt viele gerade katholische
Nordiren fühlen sich immer noch als
Bürger zweiter Klasse und die
protestantischen Unionisten die haben
Angst davor dass sie irgendwann mal hier
in der Minderheit sein könnten es wird
jetzt mit Spannung hier einen eine
Zensus erwartet eine Umfrage um zu
schauen ist eventuell jetzt vielleicht
sogar eine katholische
Bevölkerungsmehrheit da es war bis jetzt
immer so dass die Protestanten hier auch
zahlenmäßig in der Mehrheit waren
deswegen ist der Nordirland vom Rest der
irischen Republik abgetrennt worden das
könnte sich jetzt ändern und das schürt
natürlich
Ängste auf Seiten der Unionisten und
natürlich Hoffnung auf Seiten derer die
gerne zu Irland gehören möchten und da
muss Charles eben auch eine Rolle
spielen aber er kann auch nur eine
symbolische Rolle spielen und da wird
von ihm zumindest von den Unionisten
hier in Nordirland noch eine Menge
erwartet
Andreas Weise vielen Dank für diese
Analyse was die politische Situation
angeht und das Verhältnis zwischen König
Charles dem dritten und seinen
Untertanen in Nordirland schon ein
bisschen noch auf die Bilder die uns das
britische Fernsehen hier anbietet sie
entstehen an den Wellington Barracks
also einem Kasernengelände und wir sehen
wie hier
berittene Truppenteile sich vorbereiten
um die Lafette dann zum Buckingham
Palace zu ziehen auf der der sagt mit
den sterblichen Überresten der Königin
Elisabeth II dann vom Buckingham Palace
die Mall herunter zu Westminster Hall
geführt werden wird
also die militärischen Vorbereitungen
laufen welche Truppen sind denn heute
involviert Julia
sich der haushaltsdivision der Haushalt
Division 1 das sind die regimenta die im
Dienst der Königin bisher oder jetzt des
Königs stehen und früher galten sie also
eigentlich nur zum Schutz des Monarchen
heute sind sie vor allen Dingen also
auch für zeremonielle Anlässe eingesetzt
aber es sind als auch keineswegs nur ich
sag mal Zinnsoldaten und Dekoration der
Monarchie sondern man trifft sie also
auch im Kampfeinsätzen an also es gehört
beides dazu sowohl die Leibgarde der
Königin zu stellen als auch richtig im
militärischen Verband zu dienen und das
sind die beiden
ältesten Regimenter der britischen Armee
die Blues und Royals und die live-guards
die Kavallerie regimenta hier sehen wir
gerade einen Infanterie Regiment und die
königliche Familie ist also auch als
ehrenoberst für jedes dieser jedes jede
dieser Regiment dazugewiesen und wir
werden heute auch die Mitglieder der
königlichen Familie sehen also die die
Männer und dann auch Prinzessin n in
einer Uniform werden sie heute Abschied
nehmen weil sie halt die Funktion als
ehrenoberst haben um 13 Uhr soll die
Ehrengarde dann die Wellington Barracks
verlassen und die Lafette die dann den
eigentlichen Transport des Satz
übernehmen soll um 13 Uhr 40 meine Damen
und Herren und um 15 das waren jetzt
britische Zeiten die ich Ihnen genannt
habe will sie nicht irritieren was die
deutsche Zeit angeht um 15 oder 22 so
sieht das Protokoll ist auf die Minute
genau vor wird der Sarg mit dem
stattlichen Überresten von kündigen
Elisabeth II dann Buckingham Palace hier
verlassen
die Beziehung zwischen der Königin und
dem Militär war sehr eng das kann man
wohl sagen ja sie führte sich der
Militär sehr verbunden abgesehen davon
dass alles was mit Pferden zu tun hatte
natürlich wahrscheinlicher
lieblingsverber da stimmt und es gibt ja
diese sehr schöne Geschichte oder und
und Anekdote sehr viel mehr glaube ich
weiß nicht dass sie im Krieg eine
Ausbildung zur Kfz-Mechanikerin
absolviert hat das gibt es sehr schöne
Schwarz-Weiß-Bilder wie sie sich über
den Motorraum eines militärfahrzeugs
beugt sie war die Militär zugewandt
natürlich sie war die truppenführerin
sie hat jedes Jahr die große Parade
topping the Keller abgenommen bis auf
letztes Jahr das hat sie nicht geschafft
er hat sie das schon an damals noch
Prinz Charles abgegeben in ihrer
Stellvertretung die Verbindung war
tatsächlich eng rechnen sie eigentlich
damit Julia Melchior dass das britische
Königshaus auf solche Rituale auch in
Zukunft zurückgreifen wird oder könnte
es sein dass wir solche Bilder zum
also ich kann mir überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass solche Bilder in Zukunft
nicht mehr geben wird denn das wird auch
in gewisser Weise einer vom Königshaus
erwartet solche Bilder zu liefern das
macht auch diesen Zauber des britischen
Königshauses aus und erklärt auch diese
Reichweite anders als in anderen
Königshäusern in Europa die Beziehung
zur Militär wird auch sicherlich in
Zukunft genauso von Bedeutung sein
aber es ist anzunehmen dass König
Charles III insgesamt sagen wir so das
Zeremoniell vielleicht etwas
runterfahren wird und auch die das
Königshaus dass die Firma etwas
verschlanken wird also auch nicht nur
die die Handelnden Mitglieder der
königlichen Familie sondern also auch
das Personal im Königshaus jetzt wo die
Königin gestorben ist wird sicherlich da
auch einige Umstrukturierungen erleben
während wir Diana Zimmermann jetzt die
Vorbereitungen hier im Bild
mitverfolgen können vielleicht doch noch
mal für einen Moment zurück zu dieser
politischen Frage dem Verhältnis zu
Nordirland und zu Irland das ist schon
bemerkenswert dass gestern bei seinem
Antrittsbesuch wenn man so will eben
nicht nur die Repräsentanten der das der
Provinz Nordirland anwesend waren in
Belfast sondern auch der irische König
rübergekommen ist und nicht König
Präsident und der Premierminister
gekommen sind
2011 hat grüner Elizabeth vielleicht
ihren wichtigsten Staatsbesuch gemacht
mit einem
Versöhnungsangebot an die irische Nation
sie hat in ihrer offiziellen Ansprache
ein paar Worte auf gälisch gesagt kann
Charles so eine Gäste eigentlich noch
überbieten
überbieten kann er sie wahrscheinlich
nicht aber wenn es ihm gelingt sie
aufrecht zu erhalten als Idee dann hat
er glaube ich schon viel getan er hat
seinen
Großonkel verloren durch einen Anschlag
der haben wir gerade schon gesagt und er
hat aber trotzdem der prominenten Figur
der eher Martin McGuinness die Hand
gegeben so wie die clean das auch getan
hat bei diesem Besuch
Tarzan glaube ich und er hat tatsächlich
gesagt dass er dadurch den ganzen
Konflikt besser verstehen konnte und das
ist ihm gelungen ist über seinen
persönlichen Schmerz hinauszugehen weil
es ihnen getröstet hat zu denken dass so
viele Menschen auf beiden Seiten dieses
Konflikts der über 3000 Menschenleben
gekostet hat eben etwas Ähnliches
durchgemacht haben ich fand das hat er
ziemlich gut in Worte gefasst und diese
Geste war glaube ich auch sehr wichtig
und hat ihm sicherlich in beiden Teilen
des Landes sehr viel Sympathien
angebracht nochmal zur Klarstellung war
nicht der Onkel sondern der Großonkel
von Charles damals Prince of Wales und
wie wir wissen
sagen wir mal auch einen sehr wichtiger
persönlicher Anker in einem schwierigen
Verhältnis sowohl zum Vater als auch zur
Mutter die Bilder zeigen meine Damen und
Herren wie sich die Königlichen Garden
vorbereiten um die Lafette die dann den
Sarg der Königin durch die Londoner
Innenstadt bringen wird zum Buckingham
Palace zu bringen natürlich begleitet
von Abordnungen der verschiedenen
Einheiten der britischen Streitkräfte
wir haben noch eine gute Stunde bis der
sagt dann Buckingham Palace verlassen
wird und nutzen die Zeit um uns auch
einmal umzuschauen wie für Prinz Charles
für König Charles eigentlich das
Verhältnis zu den Commonwealth Ländern
aussehen wird der ist ja Staatsoberhaupt
nicht nur das Vereinigten Königreichs
und der vier Nationen Wales Schottland
Nordirland und England sondern es immer
noch Staatsoberhaupt von 14 Ländern die
von Australien bis Kanada reichen
sie ging oft auf Reisen Elisabeth II
selbst in hohem Alter und bei
erschwerten Witterungsbedingungen
und das musste sie auch war sie ja nicht
nur die Königin der Briten sondern
beispielsweise auch aller Kanadier und
da war es sozusagen Royale Pflicht deren
Nationalfeiertag beizuwohnen wie zuletzt
im Sommer 2010
[Musik]
darüber hinaus stand die Queen auch dem
sogenannten Commonwealth vor jenes
Zusammenschlusses von über 50 Staaten
der nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg aus dem
britischen Empire hervorgegangen war
Elisabeth II hat diese Rolle während
ihrer gesamten Regentschaft sehr ernst
genommen
bekommen will
das Commonwealth hat eine sehr tiefe
Bedeutung für mich es bringt Menschen
zusammen und Bereiche deren Leben
solange wir dieses Ziel nicht aus dem
Auge verlieren bin ich mir seiner
Zukunft sicher und ich bin stolz Teil
dieser großartigen Organisation zu sein
und die Einfluss war dabei nicht zu
unterschätzen ob auf großen Konferenzen
oder Gesprächen im kleinen Kreis im
Rahmen des Commonwealth präsentierte
sich die Königin immer ganz als
Staatsfrau
für die Königin war das also das
allerwichtigste eigentlich in ihre
Regentschaft also sie hat das Oberhaupt
des kommen weil zu sein hat sie als ihre
wichtigste Aufgabe gesehen weil es
natürlich auch der Monarchie noch mal
eine Rolle gegeben hat also wenn die
Monarchie jetzt einfach nur auf
Großbritannien beschränkt gewesen wäre
dass das war zu klein und das gab ihnen
noch mal Glamour und sie hat das sehr
sehr ernst genommen dabei waren ihre
Mission nicht immer einfach da flogen
ihr bei einem Besuch in Neuseeland
einmal statt Sympathien alte lumpen und
Eier entgegen
von den Maori den Ureinwohnern dieses
Landes die waren einst unter Mithilfe
ihrer Urahnen Königin Victoria um ihre
Länder reingebracht worden
Elisabeth bewies diplomatisches Gespür
erklärte alte Verträge für ungültig und
entschuldigte sich und war seither bei
den Maori hochgeachtet
das Commonwealth konnte politisch auch
Druck ausüben jahrelang war Südafrika
wegen seiner abartheitspolitik
ausgeschlossen
ein Besuch der Königin auf Einladung
nennsten Mandelas gerieter 1995 zu einem
viel umjubelten Ereignis
doch so wie das britische Empire
zerfallen ist vor allem symbolisiert
durch die Übergabe Hongkongs an China
1997 geht auch das Commonwealth nach dem
Tod der Königin als Integrationsfigur
einer ungewissen Zukunft entgegen
im November 2021 reiste Prinz Charles
nach Barbados um dort den
Feierlichkeiten anlässlich des Übergangs
des karibikinselstaats zur Republik
beizuwohnen
Barbados bleibt zwar im Commonwealth
doch der britische Monarch ist nicht
mehr Staatsoberhaupt
[Applaus]
auch mehrere andere Karibikstaaten
wollen sich mittlerweile von der
Monarchie los sagen diesen
Stimmungswandel bekamen Prinz William
und seine Frau Catherine im Frühjahr bei
einer Reise in die Karibik deutlich zu
spüren
der Tod Königin Elisabeth könnte diesen
Prozess nun noch beschleunigen je
Nachfolger auf dem Thron Charles der
dritte wird es nicht einfach haben das
ist eben die große Frage ob Charles das
übernehmen kann also sie hatte natürlich
den Respekt und den hohen Status und die
Leute haben sie wirklich als Oberhaupt
anerkennen können das kommen weil sie
hat hart dafür gearbeitet sie wirklich
70 Jahre lang unermüdlich sich
eingesetzt aber diesen Status hat
Charles einfach nicht mehr und es war
2018 ein schwerer Fehler eigentlich dass
man ihm sozusagen das kommen wird als
Erbstück gab
Königin Elisabeth II gleichwohl hat die
Idee des Commonwealth durch ihren
Einsatz bis zuletzt am Leben gehalten
das Verhältnis der Königin zu den
Commonwealth-Staaten war herzlich auch
wenn sich diese Staaten nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg natürlich unabhängig gemacht
haben aber sie ist Staatsoberhaupt
geblieben und Charles III wird darum
kämpfen müssen ob das auch so bleibt er
verobach wenn sie in die Zukunft schauen
meinen sie dass wenn man so will die
Herrschaft des britischen Königshauses
von Sonnenaufgang bis zu Sonnenuntergang
weitergehen wird oder denken Sie können
sich als Szenario vorstellen dass da
manche auch ausbricht auf jeden Fall
wird es sehr viele geben die ausbrechen
werden es ist einfach momentan so dass
die ganze Kolonialgeschichte wieder in
den Vordergrund gerückt ist wenn wir
zurückkommen haben uns natürlich immer
damit beschäftigt wir wissen dass das
Empire auf gear und Testosteron
aufgebaut war aber jetzt ist es
natürlich auch noch mehr in die
Öffentlichkeit gekommen und ich würde
denken dass da eine zerfallserscheinung
ganz klar stattfinden wird ja wir sehen
hier wie die Truppen aufmarschiert sind
vor dem Buckingham Palace das Volk meine
Damen und Herren einem über Jahre und
Jahrzehnte
ausgeklügelten Protokoll den Vormittag
über hat sich die königliche Familie im
Palast aufgehalten wir haben gesehen wie
einzelne Gäste von außen dazugekommen
sind für einen Moment des privaten
Abschieds für 15 Uhr
deutscher Zeit 1405 britischer Zeit ist
ein Gebet ein abschiedsgebet wenn man so
will vorgesehen im bowroom in dem die
Ängste Familie sich verabschieden kann
noch einmal in einem geschützten Raum
bevor die Queen sich dann wieder in
Öffentlichkeit begibt man kann das so
sagen weil das zu ihrem politischen
Willen gehörte sich eben auch nach ihrem
Ableben nach ihrem Tod in ihrem
Königreich noch mal zu zeigen in einem
offenen Leichenwagen gestern Abend in
London gut beleuchtet durch die Londoner
Straßen und heute eben dieser grandiose
Trauerzug dann durch die Londoner
Innenstadt ein Zeremoniell das hier in
der Hauptstadt
jahrzehntelang nicht gesehen worden ist
bleiben wir aber einen Moment beim Thema
des Verhältnisses zwischen dem
Vereinigten Königreich dem Commonwealth
und auch den anderen Staaten über die
Großbritannien einmal geherrscht hat wir
wissen dass das in den sozialen Medien
eine große Rolle spielt und Kristina
Umgang Sternberg hat das beobachtet
diesen Thema dieses Thema das auch am
heutigen Tag zum Beispiel auf Instagram
Seiten des ZDF einer Rolle spielt
Christian Ungarn Starnberg vielleicht
schildern Sie mal was man dort sehen
kann und auch wie die Reaktionen sind
ja Peter frei zum einen sehen wir dass
viele Userinnen und User natürlich
gebannt sind von den Bildern die wir
hier alle live mitverfolgen können aber
wie sie sagen gleichzeitig ist das Thema
Kolonialismus eins dass viele Userinnen
und User tatsächlich beschäftigt es gab
einen Instagram Post von der ZDF heute
hier sehen wir ihn unter anderem mit
einem Zitat des kenianischen Autos
mokoma waren googi und er sagt hätte
sich die Königin für Sklaverei und
Kolonialismus entschuldigt und wieder
Gutmachung geleistet dann würde ich mich
vielleicht schlecht fühlen und trauern
aber als Kenianer fühle ich nichts
dieses Theater ist absurd und
vielen Userinnen und Usern ist es auch
wichtig dass wir in unserer
Berichterstattung auch darauf eingehen
hier in diesem Post auch viel über die
den Umgang mit britischen
kolonialverbrechen in Kenia
Kiton Berlin schreibt zum Beispiel auf
Instagram vielen Dank dass Sie auch
darüber berichtet und zur
Meinungsbildung und Einordnung beitragt
und ein anderer User oder eine Userin
endlich auf diesen Beitrag habe ich die
ganze Zeit gewartet
das ist schon auffällig Kristina wie
viele Likes dann so einen Beitrag
sammelt ist es denn eine Spezialität
sozusagen für das deutsche Internet oder
spürt man so kritische Annäherungen auch
wenn man auf internationale oder auf
britische Seiten schaut
ja das ist sehr interessant weil es vor
allem in den ehemaligen Kolonien ein
großes Thema ist zum Beispiel der
Themenkomplex kohinor coinor war ein
mehr als 100 Karat schwerer Diamant der
aus Punjab entwendet wurde viele sagen
er wurde gestohlen also er wurde den
Indern gestohlen nach Großbritannien
gebracht dann in einer Brosche für Queen
Victoria zunächst verarbeitet und dann
in einer Krone für Queen Mum und jetzt
gab es schon lange eine große Debatte in
Indien um die Rückgabe die das Diamanten
es hat auch Petitionen von indischen
Abgeordneten gegeben dass dieser Stein
zurückgegeben werden soll und jetzt
interessanterweise mit dem Tod der Queen
ist gerade auf Twitter unter indischen
Nutzerinnen und Nutzern eine Debatte
darüber ausgebrochen dass jetzt endlich
der richtige Zeitpunkt ist diese Debatte
neu zu führen diesen Stein zurückzugeben
viele andere Dinge auch und viele
indische Tageszeitungen zum Beispiel
greifen dieses Thema auch in ihrer
Berichterstattung im Internet auf
ja vielen Dank Christina Ungarn
Sternberg auch für diesen Blick
kritischen Blick in die Vergangenheit
des britischen Königshauses hier wird
sicher noch eine Menge aufgearbeitet
werden müssen
wir sind meine Damen und Herren live in
London wir sehen hier die Vorbereitungen
die militärischen Vorbereitungen zur
Überführung des Sargs mit den
staatlichen Überresten von Queen
Elizabeth II von Buckingham Palace zur
Westminster Hall
dies ist eine Lafette man könnte sagen
ein
umgebauter militärisches Fahrgerät und
ähnlich übrigens wie beim Tod von Diana
deren sagt auf einem ähnlichen Gefährt
dann durch London transportiert wird
wird der sagt von Queen Elizabeth dann
auf diese Art und Weise von Pferden
gezogen durch die Londoner Innenstadt
geleitet werden wir sehen dass die
Anteilnahme der Menschen hier groß ist
wo immer
etwas stattfindet auf der Mall dem
Prachtboulevard an Westminster Abbey
Buckingham Palace haben sich viele
versammelt man rechnet damit dass es am
Ende Millionen sein werden die an der
Queen vorbei definieren wollen in
Westminster Hall das werden nicht alle
das tun können Ihre persönliche
referenzerweisen obwohl der sagt der
Queen von heute abend
Mittwochabend bis Montagmorgen dann der
Öffentlichkeit zugänglich sein wird also
eine Frau die auch im Tod noch die
Menschen fasziniert und darüber wollen
wir sprechen mit Professor
Ute fräfert der Direktorin des
Forschungsbereichs Geschichte der
Gefühle am Max-Planck-Institut für
Bildungsforschung Frau Professor fredat
studierte in den 90er Jahren an der
London School of Economics kennt
klassischen Verhältnisse also sehr gut
Frau Professor Pfeffer sie haben die
Queen in einem Artikel für Zeit online
die
unzeitgemäße genannt wie ist das zu
verstehen hat sie ihre Zeit geprägt ist
sie mit oder ist sie gegen die Zeit
gegangen
es war ja viel davon die Rede Herr frei
gleich unmittelbar nach Elisabeths Tod
dass sie so eine prägende Kraft für ihre
Epoche gewesen sei also wie die
viktorianische Epoche oder die erste
elisabethanische Epoche ich finde das
eigentlich nicht ich finde sie hat gegen
ihre Epoche Zeichen gesetzt sie war er
hat nicht an allen Dingen und an allen
Entwicklungen und an allen Trends dieser
Epoche teilgenommen und sie hat sie vor
allen Dingen auch nicht gesetzt sondern
sie hat diesen Trends oft auch
widerstanden also wenn man sich an diese
ja an den Zusammenhang erinnert das ja
mittlerweile wir
Stars und auch Politiker zum Anfassen
möchten ist damit war nie eine Königin
zum Anfassen sie blieb immer doch
relativ für sich und relativ weit
entfernt bei aller Präsenz die sie in
Großbritannien in der in ihrer langen
Regierungszeit ja gezeigt hat aber sie
war trotzdem keine Königin zum Anfassen
sie war bekannt dafür im Gegenteil dass
sie die Öffentlichkeit praktisch nicht
an ihren Gefühlen hat teilnehmen lassen
auch in kritischen Momenten wenn wir zum
Beispiel an den Tod von Princess Diana
denken und trotzdem jetzt diese
unglaublich große
altanteilnahme woher kommt Frau fräfert
bei einer doch relativ distanzierten
Person nun plötzlich dieser Ausbruch von
des von Gefühlen und die die sehr große
öffentliche Anteilnahme
vielleicht fange ich noch mal etwas
früher an ich war Anfang Juni zufällig
in London als die Queen ihr
platinjubiläum tonjubiläum gefeiert hat
und auch damals waren Millionen Menschen
auf der Straße jedes Geschäft was auf
sich hielt
glückwünschte die Queen zu diesem
Jubiläum was ja nun wirklich auch in der
britischen Geschichte seinesgleichen
sucht also auch damals als sie noch
lebte hat man sich sozusagen in der
Queen gefeiert also dieses dieser Wunsch
sozusagen da hat man eine Symbolfigur
für das britische jetzt nicht mehr
unbedingt Empire aber Commonwealth und
die britische Nation war damals auch
schon sehr stark ausgeprägt dass sie
jetzt das jetzt vielleicht noch mehr
Menschen auf der Straße sind und zu
einem sehr viel traurigeren Anlass
natürlich hat aus meiner Sicht viel
damit zu tun dass die Queen immer in
dieser Ambivalenz ja verharrte sie war
einerseits omnipräsent auf allen Münzen
auf allen Fotos also eine unendliche
Foto
Kaskade ist ja sozusagen immer wieder
veröffentlicht worden natürlich immer
auch schön zensiert worden vom
Buckingham Palace aber sie war einfach
immer da und sie hat ja auch bis zuletzt
noch ihre vielen Termine ich glaube es
waren immer so ungefähr 500 im Jahr wo
sie jemanden besucht hat jemand etwas
eingeweiht hat wahrgenommen also ich war
einfach immer da und trotzdem war sie
nicht nicht eben da zum Anfassen sie
blieb in dieser relativen Distanz und
vor allen Dingen wie sie auch gerade
gesagt haben in dieser emotionalen
Distanz sie hat eben nicht aus ihrem hat
aus ihrem Herzen keine Mördergrube
gemacht sondern sie hat immer ob es was
Positives oder was Negatives zu feiern
oder zu begehen gab eigentlich diese
Contenance bewahrt und diese Contenance
und damit auch die Wärme und die die
Distanziertheit
sie sprechen ja Frau fevert im Artikel
auch von
gefühlspolitik sie sprechen in ihrem
Artikel auch von gefühlspolitik wie viel
steckt darin auch in dem was wir jetzt
gerade sehen diese
Traditionen diese Rituale die ja so
aussehen als sei die Welt plötzlich in
16 Jahrhundert zurückgefallen
das ist ja das Tolle an Ritualen man
muss sich nicht dauernd selber Gedanken
machen wie man einen solchen Einschnitt
der ist ja für alle Briten und Briten
sicherlich ist und auch für die
Institutionen die politischen
Institutionen des Königs heißt wie man
diesen Einschnitt nun auf besondere
Weise zu begehen hat sondern man
schreibt sich ein in eine lange
Tradition und diese Tradition entlastet
eigentlich auch ein bisschen von
Gefühlen es ist einfach alles sehr
sehr um zirkelt sehr begrenzt der
bestimmt sehr definiert zugleich
erlauben es diese Rituale den vielen
Menschen ihre eigenen Gefühle der Queen
gegenüber zum Ausdruck zu bringen und
das sind vor allen Dingen Gefühle eines
Verlustes ich würde wirklich da noch mal
auf dieses unzeitgemäße zurückkommen
wollen das Gefühl eines Verlustes einer
Person die über eine unendlich lange
Zeit da gewesen ist und die sich
verschiedenen Trends dieser
eben auch ins sehr erfolgreich entzogen
hat und damit eine gefühlspolitik ja
sozusagen gegen den Strom eigentlich
betrieben hat in ihrer Zurückhaltung und
in ihrer extremen Selbstkontrolle und
Contenance das findet man ja bei ihren
Nachfahren eher weniger und man kann
gespannt sein ob die eine genau solche
eine solche Aura des ja vornehmen
distanzierten entfalten können oder
wollen wie es Queen Elizabeth gemacht
hat
wir beobachten jedenfalls Frau Professor
Fresser das sich dieser Zauber von Queen
Elizabeth der ja so oft beschrieben
worden ist auch heute hier in London
zeigt es ist schon sehr beeindruckend
mit welcher Stille mit welcher
Konzentration die Menschen sich jetzt
vorbereiten auf diesem Moment wenn in
einer halben Stunde der sagt von Queen
Elizabeth dann aus dem puckingham Palace
herausgebracht wird
die Menschen werden immer
zurückgezogener so ist es mein Eindruck
immer ernster während das von einem
halben von einer Stunde anderthalb
Stunden ja doch noch ein bisschen mehr
nach Fröhlichkeit aussah
hier sehen wir wenn ich es richtig
erkenne Queen Camilla meine Damen und
Herren die offenbar von claren's Haus
also ihrer jetzigen Residenz darüber
gefahren wird zum Buckingham Palace um
an diesem Gebet der königlichen Familie
Zeit zu nehmen Frau fever hat eine kurze
Frage noch zum Schluss sie haben es
schon angedeutet wie schwierig wird es
für Charles den dritten sein und für
seine Nachkommen das Erbe der Queen
anzutreten und fortzuführen gerade was
diese gefühlspolitik angeht
ich glaube es wird nicht einfach sein
denn wenn er wirklich modernisiert hat
ja 70 Jahre lang fast drauf warten
müssen wenn er modernisiert dann wird er
gleichzeitig Gefahr laufen diese
besondere Aura die in der in dieser ja
in dieser Ambivalenz von da sein und
doch nicht da sein liegt diese Aura zu
zerstören und diese Aura ist es ja auch
die letztendlich diese Monarchie am
Laufen hält wenn Sie eine Alltäglichkeit
wäre wenn sie so etwas wäre dass wir in
anderen Ländern auch jeden Tag haben
dann braucht es keine Monarchie mehr sie
ist immer noch etwas Besonderes und das
Besondere ist eben in dieser liegt in
dieser Tradition in der langen langen
Dauer die ja nun diese Königin auf
besondere und sehr persönliche Weise
verkörpert hat und das zu zerstören ist
auch eine Gefahr für die Monarchie in
Großbritannien
also das wird schwer werden Tradition
und Moderne zusammenzuhalten vielen Dank
für diese Auskünfte diese Analysen an
Professor Ute fräsert Direktorin des
Forschungsbereichs Geschichte der
Gefühle am Max-Planck-Institut für
Bildungsforschung ganz herzlichen Dank
nach Berlin
meine Damen und Herren für die die sich
dazu geschaltet haben wir senden live
aus London wir sehen die Bilder aus dem
Umkreis des Buckingham Palace
viele tausende Zehntausende von Menschen
haben sich versammelt hier auf der Mall
das große Prachtboulevard das schon im
17 Jahrhundert angelegt worden ist für
solche Gelegenheiten natürlich auch für
glücklichere Gelegenheiten
wenn sich der König und seine Gäste
durch die Stadt bewegten heute kommen
die Menschen um Abschied zu nehmen von
Queen Elizabeth und verschiedene
Einheiten der britischen Streitkräfte
haben sich für dieses Zeremoniell
eingefunden die Anna Zimmermann ich habe
gerade das Gefühl jetzt bleibt die Zeit
stehen auch ihr habt getauscht das habe
ich nicht gemerkt ja okay Frau Melchior
irgendwie bleibt die Zeit stehen in
diesem Moment oder ein großer Moment der
Ruhe und Konzentration so empfinde ich
das absolut also in den letzten Minuten
hat sich die Stimmung hier total
gewandelt man merkt es kommt jetzt der
Moment dass ich auch alle irgendwie auch
besinnen darauf es wird in wenigen
Minuten nimmt auch die königliche
Familie die Position ein hier auf dem
Vorplatz vor dem Buckingham Palast haben
schon die verschiedenen Regimenter aus
der haushaltsdivision der Königin
Situation bezogen und gleich auch man
muss auch sagen ihrer ehemaligen Chefin
Geleit zu geben denn sie standen im
Dienst der Königin und es werden gleich
500 Soldaten sein aus den Regimentern
der Infanterie und der Kavallerie die
gleich der Königin ihr letztes Geleit
geben werden zu der Westminster Hall
wir haben ja gestern so eine Art
Fahrplan bekommen sozusagen mit einem
minutengenauen Ablauf es ist aber nicht
klargestellt worden bei welchen Momenten
die Kameras dabei sein können und nicht
dabei sein können also da heißt es zum
Beispiel meine Damen und Herren ich
hatte nur 50 also um diese Zeit die
königliche Familie begibt sich in
Position so wie sich auch die Lafette in
Position begibt und wir haben ein
bisschen gerätselt ob vielleicht mal mit
der Tradition bricht und dann auch
dieser Moment wie die königliche Familie
sich vorbereitet auf diesem letzten
Abschied gezeigt werden wird es wird ein
abschiedsgebet geben im Bauraum es sieht
so aus verobackt das Charles an den
Traditionen in diesem Fall festhält und
das an privater Moment sein wird
ja ich glaube dass er ist ja bekannt
dafür dass er das Protokoll sehr stark
einhält aber das ist dann vielleicht
doch ein Moment wir wissen natürlich
nicht was da alles abgeht im parking
Palace da können irgendwelche kleinen
Probleme auftauchen und der Zeitplan
könnte sich verschieben das glaube ich
kann auf jeden Fall besser
wie wie muss man sich das dort drin
jetzt vorstellen wie viel
familiäres geschieht dort jetzt wie viel
protokollarisches muss beachtet und
erledigt werden es ist ja zwischen
Charles und seinen Geschwistern zum
Beispiel immer so dass beide Dimensionen
im Raum stehen ja die familiäre aber
eben auch die protokollarische wie wird
das Sein in diesem Moment jetzt also das
ist ja eine Familie die sehr eng ist
denn sie sind halt nicht nur als Familie
immer vereint sondern sie arbeiten ja
auch richtig gehen zusammen und insofern
sehen sie sich permanent und waren sich
jetzt auch in den Tagen der der Trauer
sehr nahe also die die Kinder von
Königin Elisabeth haben die Queen ja
auch verabschiedet schon in Schottland
die Totenwache gehalten es ist gestern
Abend gab es ein sehr innigen Moment
auch als die Familie vereint war hier im
Buckingham Palast um den Sarg in Empfang
zu nehmen es ist aber auch ein sehr
einem rührender Moment für die
Mitarbeiter der Königin die also jetzt
heute auch ihre Chefin verabschieden wir
werden also auch gleich den Lord
Chamberlain das ist also sowas wie der
Vorstandsvorsitzende des Königshauses
der der Chef dieser Organisation und
auch die Schnittstelle zum zum Parlament
und zur Regierung den werden wir also
auch gleich sehen wir an den an den an
der Stufen des Buckingham Palastes die
Königin verabschieden wird also ich
glaube auch schon dass es ein sehr
besinnlicher Moment ist und ein sehr
privater Moment zwischen den Ängsten
Mitarbeitern dazu gehören natürlich auch
so die Hofdamen der Königinnen und die
die die kleiderfrau der Königin also die
auch gleich in dieses Gefolge sich
einfügen werden nun ist es ja eine sagen
wir mal nicht ganz unkomplizierte
Familie
wo es auch jede Menge Spannungen und
Konflikte und Fehltritte gibt wird das
heute spürbar sein
nein so professionell ist diese Familie
schon dass die in der Öffentlichkeit
sich nichts anmerken lassen es gibt
Spannungen in der Familie in beiden
Generationen über die Prinzen William
und Harry haben wir auch schon
gesprochen aber es gibt vor allen Dingen
auch Spannungen zwischen den
Geschwistern also mit mit Prinz Andrew
der ja aber auch eigentlich von allen
königlichen Pflichten und Privilegien
entbunden worden ist und eigentlich
jetzt nur noch ein ein Familienmitglied
ist aber jetzt wird das also sicherlich
ein eine die Familie wird sich natürlich
in Eintracht zeigen
zum Beispiel die Zeichen wer darf was
anziehen und da Prinz Harry keine
offiziellen Funktion mehr hat wird er
also in Zivil zu sehen sein während sein
Onkel Prinz Andrew heute wahrscheinlich
das letzte Mal und auch das einzige Mal
noch eine Militär und uniformt wird das
wird interessant sein ich dachte er
trägt keine aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht
sicher was wir da sehen werden ich
glaube der jederzeit einmal eine Uniform
tragen das ist glaube ich vereinbart ob
das heute sein wird oder am Montag er
hat es sich von herausgenommen dass bei
der Totenwache zu tun um seiner Mutter
zum letzten Mal den Respekt zu erweisen
aber jetzt halt heute hier im Gefolge
der Könige wird er es wohl nicht tun
obwohl man muss ja auch dazu sagen dass
ausgerechnet Prinz Harry und Prinz
Andrew die jetzt also keine Uniform mehr
tragen werden diejenigen sind die dem
Militär ja auch am nächsten standen weil
sie halt auch wirklich gediente soll
Soldaten gedient haben beide an der
Front Prinz Andrew im Krieg und Prinz
Harry in Afghanistan und
Prinz Harry war zehn Jahre lang hier in
einem dieser regimenta bei den bei den
Blues und Royals die wir hier jetzt auch
sehen
sind alle Waffengattungen heute hier
vertreten um der Königin das letzte
Geleit zu geben
Kleider setzen zeichenvorobachtung genau
also die Monarchie hat sich immer über
Kleider ausgedrückt wir wissen die Queen
to Grün in Irland als Versöhnungsprozess
und die Uniformen sind in dieser Familie
natürlich sehr sehr wichtig dass ist in
den ganzen Monarchien so also dass man
sich über Uniform definiert weil die
Nähe zum zu den Streitkräften also die
Monarchie basiert ja auf diesen zwei
Säulen der Kirche und den Streitkräften
das sind die den mit denen man sich am
engsten verbündet fühlt schauen wir noch
mal meine Damen und Herren auf die
Stimmung derjenigen die sich hier heute
am Buckingham Palace versammelt haben
mein Kollege lückwald hat Stimmen
gesammelt
die Maul prachtallee vor dem Buckingham
Palast hier haben die überzeugten
Anhänger des Königshauses seit Tagen aus
bemüht den besten Platz zu erwischen für
den historischen Abschied von der
Monarchien
seit sieben heute früh hier ja und wir
sind auch schon ziemlich müde
steht für Beständigkeit sie hält das
Land zusammen und es ist unsere
Geschichte seit tausend Jahren haben wir
eine Monarchie das ist Teil unseres
kulturerbis
ich bin kein großer Anhänger der rolls
aber sie war einfach fantastisch
das Regierungsviertel ist abgeriegelt
stoisch gelassen nehmen es die Besucher
hin schon am Morgen waren die besten
Plätze weg mit zeltschlafsack und Union
Jack ausgerüstet sind sie angereist sie
hier hat das begehrte gelbe Armband dass
sie ganz nach vorne bringt
ich bin Nummer 3 in der Schlange und wir
stehen seit Montag hier wir werden Ihnen
alles was man braucht
gekommen sind sie um der Königin die
letzte Ehre zu erweisen aber die
Stimmung ist trotz des traurigen
Anlasses auch gelöst fast wie am
Lagerfeuer die meisten hier haben
Erfahrung im warten bei royalen Anlässen
ganz vorne dabei sein
die einen haben Klappstühle und Bier
dabei andere verbinden das historische
mit dem praktischen
ich bin Studentin an der Universität in
klosterscheid wir waren gestern Abend
feiern in Garden und dachten sollten wir
hierher wir haben kurz nachgedacht und
sind entschieden ja das sollten nicht
verpassen
bis zu einer Million Besucher werden am
Montag bei der Beisetzung der Königin in
London erwartet dass die Filet am
sarginvestmenster mit den ganzen Tag und
die Nacht über bis Montag früh
fortgesetzt
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zum
zdf-spezial Trauer um Elisabeth die
zweite das sind Live Bilder aus London
[Musik]
verschiedene Truppenteile sammeln sich
hier die gleich den
Sarg mit den stattlichen Überresten von
Queen Elizabeth begleiten werden vom
Buckingham Palace
über die Mall horse God's Parade durch
das Regierungsviertel bis zu Westminster
Hall
wir zeigen Ihnen diesen Weg einmal
Buckingham Palace das Symbol für die
britische Monarchie die Königin liebte
diesen Palast nicht besonders obwohl er
den größten Privatgarten in London hat
den letzten Jahren lebte sie lieber in
Winzer oder in Schottland
der Victoria Brunnen und dann der Weg
rechts der königliche St James Park
links die morgen mit anderen
repräsentativen Gebäuden dort liegt zum
Beispiel auch Clarence House wo heute
König Charles als Prinz of Wales gelebt
hat Horst garden
the colour immer stattgefunden hat also
der das Exerzieren das Pferde Exerzieren
dass die Queen so geliebt hat und dann
der Zug nach Westminster Hall im elften
Jahrhundert gebaut einst die größte
gotische Halle in England und
möglicherweise auch auf dem
europäischen Kontinent und jetzt ab 15
Uhr beginnt das Ehren salut
Vorbereitungen im Hydepark
alle Waffengattungen sind vertreten
wie die Marine wir sehen auch
Soldatinnen
und übrigens auch so ein Eindruck aus
London in diesen Tagen wie Bund und
multikulturell diese Gesellschaft
geworden ist also es stirbt hier nicht
nur
die englische Königin und das wird ihrer
gedacht sondern die Repräsentantin eines
bunt gewordenen Landes
stimmt im Verhältnis zu vor 70 Jahren
ist das deutlich diverser geworden man
es gibt tatsächlich auch Mitglieder aus
dem Commonwealth die britische Bürger
sind nicht weiße britische Bürger die in
den regimenta natürlich dienen man muss
allerdings auch sagen dass die
Zustimmung der Queen zu der Queen unter
den nicht weißen Briten deutlich
geringer ist als unter den weißen Briten
da liegt sie nur bei etwa 50%
[Musik]
es war ja in diesen Tagen viel die Rede
von der softpower also der sanften macht
die die Queen ausüben konnte und ich
glaube man kann sagen dass die diese
Bilder die ja in der ganzen Welt
übertragen werden und faszinieren nicht
zuletzt auch in Deutschland ein bisschen
von dieser softpower auch ausdrucken
über mich ja gut das ist halt auch die
letzte Monarchie in Europa die das so
zelebriert die die Feierlichkeiten
begeht in diesem Maße das Militär so
einbindet und wir wissen ja auch von der
Queen dass sie das in höchstem Maße
genossen hat also das ist auch eine
Ehrerbietung an die Königin eben dieser
dieser Zeremonien die wir heute hier
sehen
die berühmten Bärenfellmützen sind dabei
sämtliche Waffengattungen aus der aus
der Royal Air Force der Navy dem her und
auch schließlich die Royal Marines
werden heute den Sarg begleiten vom
Buckingham Palast zur Westwind Star holt
die bis Geleit der des Militärs wird
gestellt aus den sieben leibregimentern
der Königin oder des jetzt des Königs
früher standen sie zum Schutz des
Staatsoberhauptes zur Verfügung heute
dienen sie vor allen Dingen auch dem
Schutz aber vor allen Dingen auch den
zeremoniellen Anlässen dienen aber auch
selbst im Kampfeinsätzen und sind auch
die regimenta dabei bei denen also auch
die Mitglieder der königlichen Familie
selbst gedient haben
und darunter natürlich auch die Prinzen
William und Prinz Harry
und die Mitglieder der königlichen
Familie die also auch noch einen eine
Funktion inne haben als ehrenoberst
dieser regimenta werden also auch heute
als
eine Uniform tragen
das ist aber ein Privileg was nur für
die working Royals wie sie genannt
werden also die Mitglieder der
königlichen Familie die also auch im
Dienst des Staatsoberhauptes stehen und
auch Aufgaben für den neuen König
wahrnehmen können die dürfen also auch
heute eine eine Uniform tragen das sind
natürlich die der Bruder Prinz Edward
und die Schwester Prinzessin n Prinz
William und dazu gehört auch noch der
Vetter der Queen der Duke of Gloster der
heute also auch einen Teil des Ehren
Geleits geben wird gleich sie alle
werden wir dann sehen wenn der sagt dann
hinausgefahren wird von Buckingham
Palace werden die männlichen auch
interessant green eines aber auch dabei
vor allem männliche Mitglieder der
Familie werden hinter dem Sarg herlaufen
wir sehen hier viele Menschen die sich
versammelt haben die Stimmen haben wir
schon gehört aber meine Damen und Herren
wir wollen hier nicht ein allzu
royalistisches Bild zeigen von
Großbritannien und haben deshalb auch
ein paar kritische Stimmen gesammelt auf
den Straßen Londons wo nicht jeder sich
in dieser Weise mit der Queen
identifiziert wie diejenigen die heute
hierher gekommen sind auch die sollen zu
Wort kommen
momentan ist das alles noch zu
altmodisch es ist zu groß und kostet
viel zu viel Geld für Leute die in etwas
hineingeboren wurden dass sie sich nicht
ausgesucht haben ganz ehrlich vielen
Leuten ist die Monarchie egal ich bin
einer von ihnen
aus Irland die Beziehungen zwischen
Großbritannien und Irland sind ja schon
immer angespannt damit bin ich
aufgewachsen ich habe die Krone nie
besonders geschätzt
das Empire war in der Kolonialzeit sehr
aggressiv und ich sehe immer noch
Überreste dieser Art zu regieren und
Teile der weltkolonialisiert zu haben
sie lehrt ja die Menschen dass man etwas
besseres ist wenn man in eine bestimmte
Familie oder an einem bestimmten Ort
geboren wurde und das sollte man den
Kindern nicht beibringen
es ist nicht der beste Weg Steuergeld
auszugeben ich bin keine royalistin mehr
eine Republikanerin und ich denke es ist
für das Vereinigte Königreich auch eine
Art seine Macht zu zeigen
persönlich hat sie mir doch nichts
gebracht ich zahle Steuern für sie seit
Jahren sie hat nichts für mich getan und
ich habe dafür bezahlt dass sie in
Abstand lebt ohne irgendeinen Grund und
an ihrer Beerdigung kriege ich noch
nicht mal einen Tag frei es ist mir
wirklich egal
also ein paar kritische Stimmen gibt es
auch die wollten wir Ihnen nicht
vorenthalten an diesem Tag der
von Trauer und Anteilnahme geprägtes
wir sehen hier tausende Zehntausende von
Briten Blumen in den Händen die Abschied
nehmen wollen und die dann einen letzten
Blick auch erhaschen wollen auf
Elisabeth die zweite wir waren die an
der Zimmermann ja beim Thema softpower
das ist eigentlich die macht diese
Königin und ich fand einen interessanten
Satz im Spiegel im spiegelportrait über
Queen Elizabeth dort wurde sie die
letzte lebende Verbindung im Britanniens
faszinierende wenn auch nicht immer
glorreiche Vergangenheit als Weltmacht
genannt
ich glaube das war gut ausgedrückt oder
sehr schön hat der Kollege das
ausgedrückt tatsächlich ja natürlich als
sie als sie an die Macht kam gab es das
Empire noch weltumspannend und dann
haben sich in den Jahrzehnten danach
sehr viele Länder davon losgesagt und
Großbritannien beschränkt sich jetzt
eben nur noch auf die Inseln hier die 14
Nationen außerhalb des Königreichs die
die Knie noch als Staatsoberhaupt haben
das haben wir vorhin ja schon besprochen
davon schicken sich ohnehin einige an
sich von diesem britischen
Staatsoberhaupt zu befreien dass ihnen
in einer chronistisch erscheint in
diesen Zeiten
Julia Melchior in diesen Minuten ist
vielleicht der persönlichste Teil dieses
Abschieds für die königliche Familie
genau in diesen Minuten eingefunden im
Buckingham Palast am Sarg der Queen und
wird dort das Gebet sprechen das geführt
wird von der Bischöfin von London der
persönlichen Dekanen auch der der
königlichen Kapellen und Kirchen und das
ist also jetzt der Moment und man spürt
es hier förmlich jetzt gerade im vor dem
Buckingham Palast das ist also auch ganz
besonders still geworden ist es unter
einen Moment der Ruhe und alle gehen
noch mal in sich denn ins dauert nur
noch wenige Minuten bis die Sargträger
Position beziehen und der sagt dann aus
dem Buckingham Palast auf das auf die
geschützler fette gehoben wird
ja unsere Kamera fängt verschiedene
Bilder ein hier sind wir in horse Guard
Parade also dem
Exerzierplatz
auf dem die Königin selber oft ihre
Truppen inspiziert hat bei Shopping the
color
die königliche Familie durch diesen
Torbogen fahren darf und der ist auch
nur dann geöffnet und heute ist dieser
Moment wo dann also die Prozession durch
diesen Torbogen gehen wird sie wird noch
mal mitten über diesen Platz gefahren
werden das ist kein protokollarischer
Zufall
es ist heute wir verabschieden das
langjährige Staatsoberhaupt
Großbritanniens den das Symbol dieser
Monarchie und
wir sehen dass die ganzen Menschen also
auch jetzt sehr still geworden sind
vor dem Buckingham Palace haben die
verschiedenen Truppenteile Aufstellungen
genommen
an der sogenannten Grant entrance also
unmittelbar vor dem Palast in der
Umzäunung aber auch dann schon im
äußeren Bereich das ist nochmal
hausguard für Raid glaube ich diese
Bilder mit dem Monument hier
und die fast fröhliche Stimmung die
Andreas Stamm und zu Beginn der
Übertragung geschildert hat hat sich
doch geändert meine Damen und Herren man
spürt hier eine
Konzentration
es war in den letzten Tagen hier in
Großbritannien viel von creeve die Rede
also von
Kummer bekümmernis
es ist immer schwer Gefühle zu lesen ich
würde das jetzt nicht unbedingt lesen
hier die Trauer Nachricht ist ja auch
nicht mehr frisch aber die Menschen
kommen um ernste Abschied zu nehmen von
einer Frau die und das ist vielleicht
das ein das eigentliche Geheimnis von
Queen Elizabeth die immer da war ein
ganzes Leben lang da war alle die nach
1953 geboren sind haben keine andere
Königin gekannt und auch eine Königin
dieses ganze Volk verbindet also es ist
ja doch über alle Generationen hinweg
und auch über alle
verschiedenen Bevölkerungsschichten
eigentlich hinweg dass sie dieser Person
Respekt erhalten Sie mögen keine Freunde
von der Monarchie sein aber es sind doch
eigentlich alle Menschen
haben diese Königin sehr respektiert für
ihr Lebenswerk für ihren Dienst für
diese Nation und das ist auch etwas und
das ist glaube ich auch der große Sinn
dieser Monarchie diesen vereinenden
Charakter zu haben nämlich die Menschen
zu verbinden
und wir sehen das ja auch an Momenten
wie dem platinjubiläum dass wir vor
wenigen Monaten begangen haben oder halt
jetzt auch diesen Moment der nationalen
Trauer dass das sehr viele Menschen auf
die Straßen führt und das auch das
dominante Thema ist halt hier in der
Gesellschaft der der Übergang von der
alten Königin auf König Charles den
dritten
schon sehr erstaunlich Diana Zimmermann
und wir sehen ja auch die Gesichter von
Menschen erkennbar mit
Migrationshintergrund dass trotz aller
Diskussionen die wir eben auch selber
geführt haben über das koloniale Erbe
über den Raub von Kulturgütern über die
Dominanz eines
imperialen Reichs Empire war der Titel
es Großbritannien doch dann am Ende sehr
gut gelungen ist viele wahrscheinlich
hunderttausende Millionen von Migranten
aus der Karibik aus Indien aus Pakistan
sozusagen diese Gesellschaft zu
integrieren und vielleicht hat das auch
mit der Green zu tun die sich sozusagen
auf eine ganz unidiologische Weise auch
als
Kristallisationspunkt der Identifikation
angeboten hat also in ihrer
Zurückhaltung konnte auch der
Einwanderer aus Jamaika sagen sie ist
meine Königin
ja das ist der Clean sicherlich gelungen
aber das bedeutet nicht dass dieses Land
von vielen dieser Migranten nicht nach
wie vor als rassistisch empfunden wurde
es gibt sogar einen Bericht der den
Großbritannien
institutionalisierten Rassismus vorwirft
aber natürlich die clean hat sich sehr
stark für das coverworld eingesetzt die
Queen hat hat tatsächlich ihre Bürger
oder ihre Untertanen alle gleich
behandelt sie hat genauso Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund empfangen und
ermutigt auf ihrem Weg Gutes zu tun
meistens wie alle anderen auch und bei
den vielen vielen Geschichten die jetzt
in den letzten Tagen wieder hochgekommen
sind wo Menschen davon berichten wie sie
die kriegen getroffen haben da sind eben
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund ganz
genauso dabei wie alle anderen
die Vorbereitungen in Buckingham Palace
das sind Bilder aus dem
Vorhof des Schlosses
und durch das Fenster konnte man gerade
auch schon sehen dass die königliche
Familie und die Bischöfin von London
sich im Buckingham Palast gerade in
Bewegung gesetzt haben
sie begleiten den Sarg jetzt hier raus
zum grand-andrance des Buckingham
Palastes
im Innenhof des großen Schlosses
wird jetzt der Sarg auf die Lafette
gebracht werden es gibt noch einen
Moment der Diskretion meine Damen und
Herren dort
können die Kameras auch des britischen
Fernsehens nicht hinreichend
wir haben eben schon gesprochen über
private Momente und öffentliche Momente
und der Tag so wie wir ihn heute erleben
ist eine Mischung davon der Vormittag
bis jetzt war der privaten Trauer
vorbehalten die Familie hat sich noch
einmal gesammelt und eigentlich kann man
sagen Julia Melchior in dem Moment wo
der Sarg den Buckingham Palace verlässt
beginnt wieder das öffentliche Leben ein
öffentlicher Auftritt dieser Queen auch
fünf Tage nach ihrem Tod
komplett in den Dienst dieses Landes zu
stellen die Trauer wird öffentlich
stattfinden und die Königin wird heute
das ist ja auch deshalb ein sehr
wichtiger Moment dieses dieses
Abschiedes übergeben von dem Sinnbild
der Monarchie aus dem Buckingham Palast
heraus
wird der überführt gleich zum Herz der
Demokratie nämlich dem Palace of
Westminster wo die beiden Hauses of
Parlaments Tagen und die Menschen
bekommen heute die Gelegenheit und in
den nächsten Tagen dort Abschied zu
nehmen von der Königin die ihr ganzes
Leben in den Dienst des Landes gestellt
hat wir sehen den Buckingham Palast und
die Fahne die dort oben weht ist nicht
auf Halbmast das heißt nicht dass dieser
Palast nicht Trauer trägt sondern es ist
die Standarte des Königs und der
Verstorbenen Königin die ich Standarte
des Staatsoberhauptes die immer weht die
nie auf Halbmast gesetzt ist das ist das
Symbol der Monarchie die halt nie endet
und seit 1000 Jahren über den Stab
Wechsel von einer Generation zur
nächsten fort lebt um 15 Uhr 22 also in
sehr wenigen Minuten soll der Trauerzug
sich in Bewegung setzen
ich glaube die Queen war sich ihrer
Macht aber auch ihrer Ohnmacht sehr
bewusst jedenfalls gibt es einen Zitat
aus dem Jahr 1957 wo sie an Erfolg
gerichtet gesagt hat ich kann euch nicht
in die Schlacht führen ich kann euch
keine Gesetze geben ich kann nicht
einmal Recht sprechen aber ich kann
etwas anderes ich kann euch und diesen
alten Inseln und allen Völkern unserer
Bruderschaft mein Herz schenken und
meine Hingabe
ich glaube das bringt zwar nicht ganz
gut auf den Punkt
jemand hat einen Amt jede hingabung
hingebungsvoller erfüllt als Königin
Elisabeth II und das ist ja auch das
wofür ihr die ganze Welt Respekt
erwiesen hat Präsident Obama hatte
gesagt anlässlich des platinjubiläums
vor wenigen Monaten von über die
Bedeutung dieser Königin gesprochen als
als kontinuierliche und stabile Instanz
in der einer der größten Demokratien der
Welt und dass sie dadurch aber allein
durch ihre Präsenz die Welt ein Stück
sicherer und besser gemacht hat ich
schlag vor meine Damen und Herren dass
wir jetzt erstmal so halten wie die
Menschen die sich hier versammelt haben
es sind nur wenige Minuten bis der Sarg
herausgetragen wird und wir folgen dem
Bildern
der konzentrierten Atmosphäre
und der Trauer
[Musik]
der Trauerzug für
Queen Elizabeth II hat sich in Bewegung
gesetzt
er sagt
geschmückt mit der königlichen Krone und
bedeckt mit dem königlichen Banner im
Royal Standard verlässt
Buckingham Palace
[Musik]
auf ihrem Weg durch die Londoner
Innenstadt
wird Queen Elizabeth begleitet
von ihren Kindern
und dem innersten Kreis
ihrer Familie
die staatskrone
mit dem Rubin des schwarzen Prinzen
bedeckt den Sack
der Royal Standard zeigt
drei goldene Löwen
für England
einen roten Löwen für Schottland und
einer Harfe für Irland
[Musik]
der Trauerzug umkreist nun das Denkmal
für Queen Victoria
auch deren
sagenhaft lange Regierungszeit
hat
[Musik]
Elisabeth
überboten
70 Jahre lang stand sie für
Großbritannien
[Musik]
1926 geboren
Nachfolgerin
ihres Vaters Georg des sechsten
hier sehen wir Ihre Kinder
princess and in der Mitte rechts von ihr
King Charles III
Prinz Andrew
und Prinz Edward in der ersten Reihe
gefolgt von den Enkeln der Königin
Prinz William der neue Prince of Wales
der Titel ist mit dem Tod der Königin
hat Prinz Charles oder König Charles er
veranlasst dass sein Sohn automatisch
der neue Prince of Wales ist der Titel
der den Thronfolger total wird und wir
hören jetzt gerade den salut aus dem
Hyde Park zu Ehren der Königin
jede Minute soll dieser Not jetzt
geschossen werden
[Musik]
zum Gefolge gehören auch andere
Familienmitglieder der Queen wir sehen
gerade die weiteren männlichen Enkel die
an dieser Trauerzug teilnehmen Prinz
Harry und Peter Philipps der Sohn von
Prinzessin Anne
flankiert wird die geschützler Fette mit
dem Sarg der Königin von Vertretern
aller drei Waffengattungen aus dem Heer
der Royal Air Force und der Royal Navy
sowie der Royal Marines deren Captain
general Prinz Philip über viele viele
Jahrzehnte war
ja das sind Bilder wie sie
wahrscheinlich nur die britische
Monarchie aufbieten können
Zentimeter genau ausgedacht
eine große Wirkung der man sich kaum
entziehen kann
[Musik]
in dem Trauerzug sehen wir nur die
männlichen Mitglieder der Königsfamilie
mit Ausnahme von Prinzessin Ellen der
Tochter der Verstorbenen Königin die
Damen des Hauses also Königin Camilla
dann die neue Prinzessin von Wales Kate
wie auch Sophie die Frau von Prinz
Edwards und Meghan die Frau Prinz Harry
werden gleich parallel dazu mit den
Wagen zum Palace of Westminster gebracht
es geht entlang der Mall der
Prachtboulevard in London und manche
erinnert sich noch das zum 90 geburtstag
der Queen sechs Jahre ist das her hier
ein Picknick gefeiert wurde mit über
10.000 Menschen auch damals ging es
darum möglichst viele teilhaben zu
lassen
dort an der Mall ist mein Kollege
Andreas Stamm und vielleicht kann können
Sie Andreas auch einmal aus der
Perspektive der Menschen die eben zu
diesem Trauerzug hierhergekommen sind
seit Stunden warten
schildern wie diese Szenen dort
aufgenommen werden Prinz William hier
hinter seinem Vater dem König Charles
dem dritten Prinz William jetzt der
Prince of Wales Andreas Stamm
ja es Recken natürlich alle die Hälse
denn noch ist der Sarg mit grüne
Elizabeth so 100 150 Meter entfernt
würde ich schätzen aber was wir eben
auch angesprochen haben die Stimmung
verändert sich natürlich jetzt merklich
von von Feierlaune geht es langsam ja in
einer etwas traurigere Stimmung aber
noch eben
wird das etwas dauern bis er sagt hier
an uns vorbei zieht so auf der halben
Strecke zwischen Palast und horseguard
wir kommen gleich noch mal dann zu Ihnen
zurück Andreas Stamm
eindrucksvolle Bilder hier aus dem alten
und dem neuen London die Versöhnung von
Tradition und Moderne das ist eigentlich
das Programm des Königshauses
Charles and
William und Harry da ja irgendwie
erinnern diese Bilder an einer Ereignis
vor 25 Jahren ja da mussten der kleine
Harry und der kleine William hinter dem
Sarg ihrer Mutter hergehen und Namen
Abschied und Harry hat in Folge dieses
Ereignisses gesagt dass ein vollkommen
traumatisch für ihn gewesen dieses
Gefühl dass er nicht weinen darf während
alle um ihn herum weinten die seine
Mutter natürlich trotzdem viel weniger
nahe standen als er und er hat gesagt
dass er sich davon eigentlich nie wieder
richtig erholt hat und daran denkt er
jetzt sicherlich auch
zumal die Großmutter ja eine große Rolle
auch gespielt hat im Leben der beiden
Prinzen William und Harry beide
Großeltern Elisabeth und Philipp
waren eigentlich so dann auch so der der
Zufluchtsort für die für die Kinder die
initen auf die Schule gegangen sind und
am Wochenende dann auch sehr häufig bei
den Großeltern fußläufig auf Schloss
Windsor dann sich eingefunden hatten und
da auch ihre familiäre Nähe und diese
listwärme bekommen haben von ihrer
geliebten Granny
hier bewegt sich der Sarg mit dem
Leichnam von Queen Elizabeth II durch
das Zentrum von London
geschmückt mit der Krone es gibt viele
Zitate über Königin Elisabeth eines das
mich besonders berührt hat kommt von den
Maori dem Volk aus Neuseeland dort
nannte man Elisabeth den weißen Reiher
der Einzel fliegt
und König Charles
der nun seit
fünf Tagen
dieses Amt ausübt
damit sich ja eine Bürde trägt eng
begleitet wird vom Radschlag seiner
Schwester an hat zum 50 Thronjubiläum
von Queen Elizabeth gesagt sie sei ein
Leuchtturm der Tradition und der
Stabilität inmitten tiefgreifender und
manchmal gefährlicher Umbrüche
ich denke wir sprechen noch mal Andreas
Stamm an
Andreas
sie stehen mittendrin
wie stellt sich dieses Szene für Sie da
ja wir erkennen in der Ferne jetzt
[Musik]
den den Sarg mit
der davor Laufenden
Militärkapelle und
natürlich wie es heute
üblich ist gehen eine Menge
mobilfunkelefone in die Höhe und
ja auch die letzten Lacher sind jetzt
verstummt muss man sagen auf diesem
Moment haben natürlich alle gewartet
aber vielleicht auch alle ein bisschen
gefürchtet denn das nimmt jetzt
natürlich bisschen die die feierliche
Stimmung die hier durchaus war
also ein Tag der schwankt wenn man das
so sagen kann zwischen Dankbarkeit
einer Feier dieses großen Lebens
Trauer Abschied
also man wird sagen können dass
Großbritannien heute durch eine ganze
Mühle verschiedener Gefühle geht
und sich jetzt bewusst wird dass die
Frau auf die sich diese Nation immer
verlassen konnte
und die für die ganze Welt ein Abbild an
Symbol
für Großbritannien war
dass sie nun
abgetreten ist
es ist ja dieser Tage oft erinnert
worden an ihr
großes Versprechen dass sie zum 21
Geburtstag in Kapstadt abgegeben hat
ihr ganzes Leben den Dienst an ihnen
und an unserer großen imperialen Familie
zu widmen das Versprechen Julia Melchior
hat sie eingehalten und dieses
Versprechen war Thema auch der Ansprache
an die Nation von König Charles dem
dritten am Freitagabend er hat an den
das Versprechen seiner Mutter erinnert
und hat dieses Versprechen in seiner
Ansprache auch erneuert dass er sich wie
seine Mutter in den Dienst der Nation
stellen möchte und das ist halt auch der
Hinweis dass wir davon ausgehen können
das ist ein sehr sanften Übergang gibt
von der Regentschaft von Königin
Elisabeth II auf die Regentschaft von
König Charles dem dritten
[Musik]
es ist in jeder Zeitung auf dieser Welt
in jedem Fernsehprogramm auf dieser Welt
in den letzten Tagen über Queen
Elizabeth geschrieben und gesprochen
worden
wir wissen nicht was alles davon war ist
vielleicht ist auch ein manches ein
bisschen schöner ausgefallen als es in
Wirklichkeit war
was aber ein interessantes Zeugnis war
der außergewöhnlichen Persönlichkeit von
der späteren Königin Elisabeth II ist
eine Bemerkung die
Winston Churchill 1928 gemacht hat als
er Finanzminister war und der Familie
von
Elizabeth von der niemand ahnen konnte
dass sie einmal Königin werden würde ein
Besuch abgestattet hat und damals von
einer erstaunlichen
Ära Aura von Autorität gesprochen hat
und der gleiche Winston Churchill hat zu
ihrer Krönung
1953 gesagt wenn alle Filmleute den
Globus abgesucht hätten hätten sie
niemanden finden können der für diese
Rolle besser geeignet gewesen wäre
[Musik]
ja sie selbst hat ja immer gesagt sie
wäre auch gerne eine Landfrau geworden
weil sie sich mit Pferden und Hunden
besonders gut verstand aber sie hat ihre
Aufgabe unter den Menschen eben wirklich
auch ganz hervorragend gemacht
ja in einer Mischung aus
natürlicher Reserviertheit
Bodenständigkeit die sie dann besonders
in Schottland leben konnte
ausgeprägtem Pflichtgefühl
und der strikten Auffassung dass ihre
Rolle eine religiöse Rolle ist ein Gott
gegebenes Amt und auch ein Amt in dem
sie Gott dienen muss
sie war ja eine zutiefst fromme Frau und
es wurde ja häufig auch gefragt warum
diese Königin nicht zu dem Zeiten
abgedankt hat und das stand für sie nie
zu Debatte denn es war eine göttliche
Verpflichtung und auch Gott konnte nur
derjenige sein der ihr dieses Amt wieder
nimmt
[Musik]
sehr ernster Blick jetzt von Prinz Harry
der eine Großmutter zu Grabe trägt nach
schwierigen Jahren mit seiner Familie
ist es aber eine persönliche Gäste dass
er in einer Reihe mit seinem Bruder
hinter diesem Sarg
Herr marschiert das ist ja fast ein
persönlicher Moment auch gewesen in dem
Königin Elisabeth gegangen ist weil
Prinz Harry
für ein Projekt dass er unterstützt die
Invictus Games gerade in Großbritannien
und auch in Deutschland zu Besuch war in
der letzten Woche und er war nach langer
Zeit mal wieder in der Heimat und was
fühlt sich fast so an als hätte die
Königin gesagt sie hatte Boris Johnson
verabschiedet sie hatte eine neue
Premierministerin mit der
Regierungsbildung beauftragt und ihr
Enkel harry war in greifbarer Nähe als
hätte sie gesagt sie hätte jetzt
loslassen können und es scheint auch so
dass die Familie sich über dem Totenbett
der Königin die Hand gereicht hat
die Damen außer Prinzessin fahren
in Limousinen hinter diesem
Trauermarsch her
hinter dem Henkeln Harry William und
Peter Philipps sehen wir auch den Duke
of Gloster in Uniform und dem Vetter der
Queen und auch den Earl of Snowden das
ist der Sohn der verstorbenen Prinzessin
Margaret der Schwester von Königin
Elisabeth
[Musik]
eine prachtvolle Kulisse der Zug
erreicht jetzt das Ende der Mall und
biegt dann nach rechts
hin zu diesem
Exerzierplatz
Horse Guards parades den die Queen auch
jedes Jahr solange sie konnte genutzt
hat um dort ihre Truppen zu inspizieren
hoch zu Ross meist im Juni wurde dann
auch ihr Geburtstag gefeiert der
eigentlich im April ist aber man wusste
schon damals wie man sich gegen das
Regenwetter auf der Insel schützt
sind ja dieser Tage oft Analogien
gezogen worden zu den beiden anderen
großen Königinnen die Großbritannien
hervorgebracht hat
Victoria darüber haben wir schon
gesprochen ebenfalls mit einem deutschen
Mann aber eben auch Elisabeth die erste
diesen Vergleich mochte
Elisabeth II eigentlich gar nicht und
sie hat sich mal dazu auf eine wenig
diplomatische Weise sehr menschlich
geäußert und sagte ich fühle mich offen
gestanden überhaupt nicht wie meine
große tudora Vorfahren die weder mit
einem Ehemann gesegnet war die als
despotin herrschte und ihre heimischen
Gefilde nie verlassen konnte
also wenn man das positiv wendet war
sich Elizabeth des Glücks bewusst eine
stabile Beziehung zu führen
in der es auch ein paar Schwankungen gab
wie wir wissen in den 50er und 60er
Jahren trotzdem eine stabile
Partnerschaft
sie betrachtete sich nicht als despotin
sondern als Repräsentantin und fühlte
sich dem Parlament verpflichtet
dorthin wo auch dieser Trauerzug jetzt
geht
und sie konnte ihre heimischen Gefilde
verlassen und sie hat das ausgiebig
getan mit mehr als 100 Auslandsreisen
da sonst noch niemand reiste
und wo sie wahrscheinlich in vielen
Ländern die erste Frau aus
Großbritannien waren die überhaupt
gesehen
[Musik]
ja manches hat Wien Elisabeth ohnehin
zum ersten Mal getan also ihre Krönung
1953 ließ sie im damals jungen Medium
Fernsehen übertragen weil sie wusste so
erreicht sie ihre
doch auch nach geöffnet hat für die
Menschen einmal natürlich die
Übertragung der krönungsfeierlichkeiten
ermöglicht hat und auch jetzt sehen wir
gerade wie die Damen des Hauses den
Buckingham verlassen Buckingham Palast
verlassen hier im ersten Wagen ein Blick
auf Königin Camilla und die neue
Prinzessin von Wales
Königin Camilla hatte den hatte den
Titel der Queen concert erst vor wenigen
Monaten
zugestanden bekommen auf es war einen
ausdrücklicher Wunsch der Königin das
Camilla also auch eine titulare Königin
wird das war lange nicht
selbstverständlich und es wird sich
sicherlich auch in
kurzer Zeit einbürgern dass man von
Königin Camilla spricht und nicht mehr
von dem korrekter Weise Queen concert
Königs Gemahlin Camilla spricht sondern
sie ist die neue Königin an der Seite
von König Charles dem dritten und eine
wichtige Stütze für ihn auch
ja und das liegt ja gar nicht lange her
dass Elisabeth II auch an dieser Stelle
für Klarheit gesorgt hat ich glaube ja
immer mal wieder auf Forderungen Charts
sollte auf den Thron verzichten nach der
unglücklichen Geschichte seine ersten
Ehe mit Diana aber
Elisabeth hat klargestellt das Camilla
Königin werden kann und sie hat den Weg
frei gemacht und sie wird zusammen mit
Charles auch geträumt werden ja es ist
ein formeller Akt also sie wird auch
eine tatsächlich gekrönt oder eine Krone
aufgesetzt bekommen aber wir bleiben
natürlich viele Teile dieses
krönungszeremoniels vorbehalten
Großbritannien ist auch die einzige
Monarchie in Europa überhaupt die
überhaupt solche Feierlichkeiten noch
zulässt aber auch krönungsfreiheiten
andere Königin Europa werden gar nicht
mehr gekrönt und das Camilla jetzt die
neue Königin von Großbritannien sein ist
ein Zeichen des Respekts wir gegenüber
sie hat sich in all den Jahren als ein
sehr loyaler und diskreter und vor allem
auch fleißiger Partner und ein sehr
fleißiges Mitglied dieser königlichen
Familie gezeigt
und sie hat auch eine einen sehr guten
und beruhigenden Einfluss auf Charles
gehabt in all den Jahren aber sie war
mal die
meist gehasste Frau der Nation die Wut
hat sich damals auf ihr entladen aber
sie hat halt durchgehalten und für diese
Beständigkeit in ihrer Liebe
genießen auch König Charles und Königin
Camille beide heutzutage eigentlich auch
großen Respekt
hat das Jahr hat das Paar auch viele
Jahre gearbeitet
hat gearbeitet auch mit pa-maßnahmen
gearbeitet um sich diese Position um
diese Position zu erringen aber jetzt
ist sie da und es hat in den letzten
Tagen keine nennenswerten Proteste
gegeben gegen Charles den dritten in
dieser Hinsicht ist der Machtübergang
schon vollzogen wir sind meine Damen und
Herren
live in London
das ZDF überträgt dem Trauerzug die
feierliche Prozession mit der
der Leichnamen von Elisabeth II vom
Buckingham Palace
zuvestments the hall gebracht wird nun
etwa in der Mitte des Weges
horse Guard Parade
König Charles III
[Musik]
folgt dem Sarg begleitet von seinen drei
Geschwistern Prinzessin und wie überall
auf diesem Weg und in den letzten Tagen
applaudieren die Menschen ihrer Queen
ein letztes Mal
wir haben hier Julia Melchior keine
Tränen gesehen aber wir haben wir haben
jana hat ein paar Tränen gesehen
schwer zu sagen dankbare Gesichter so
wird ich es interpretieren Julia also
unter der Bevölkerung auf jeden Fall und
man muss ja auch einfach mal sagen es
ist da ein sehr trauriger Anlass also
keine Tragödie es war ja zu erwarten
dass die Queen mit 96 Jahren und
schwindenden Kräften
einfach nicht mehr
nicht mehr lange am Leben sein würde
durch diesen Bogen zu schreiten oder zu
reiten war der königlichen Familie
vorbehalten
auch diese Tradition wird hier noch
einmal
geschworen
der Sarg mit dem königlichen Standard
und der
Krone
die beiden anderen Symbole der
Herrschaft der Reichsapfel und das
Zepter werden nachher
Investments der Abbey noch dazu kommen
der Trauerzug erreicht jetzt
das Regierungsviertel
Whitehall
mit vielen historischen Gebäuden die vor
allem für die militärische Geschichte
Großbritanniens eine große Rolle spielen
ehemaliger Sitz der Admiralität
des Verteidigungsministerium ist dort
untergebracht und dann auf dem Weg zu
Westminster Horror geht es auch vorbei
an Downing Street
es würde offensichtlich Sand
aufgeschüttet damit die Queen sanft
rollt
vielleicht spürt man jetzt auch in
diesem innehalten in der Konzentration
etwas von der
nationalen Befindlichkeit
Großbritanniens
in diesem Land ist ja viel zu Ende
gegangen in den letzten Tagen
zunächst der Übergang von einem
Ministerpräsidenten zur anderen List
krass
Premierminister dann der Tod der Queen
die wahrscheinlich in Aufbietung ihrer
letzten Kräfte den alten Premierminister
verabschiedet hat und die neue
Premierministerin noch vereidigt hat in
Balmoral
um sich dann zu sterben wiederzulegen
eine wirklich perfekte Inszenierung bis
zum Schluss muss man sagen und er sehr
lange kann sie nicht gelitten haben sie
so wurde berichtet von allen die das
Wochenende vor ihrem Sterben noch mit
ihr verbracht haben dass sie in bester
Verfassung gewesen sei sehr gut gelaunt
gescherzt habe und die Gesellschaften
abends und dann ist etwas die
zusammengehalten habe
sie hat sich auch wohl bis zum Schluss
für Politik interessiert
und ihre Sorge zum Ukraine Krieg zum
Ausdruck gebracht über das Wochenende
[Musik]
und dann hatte sie offensichtlich das
Gefühl sie hat jetzt genug getan
die 70 Jahre der Regierungszeit sind ja
oft jetzt als Epoche geschrieben worden
sie waren aber auch eine Zeit mit
unendlich vielen Brüchen Veränderungen
Verwerfungen
sozialem Aufruhr
kulturellem Aufbruch
und das muss man wohl sagen
Großbritannien ist im Moment was die
Politik angeht nicht in der besten
Verfassung
der Aufruhr ist weitergegangen auch der
Aufruhr in der
regierenden Partei mit dem vierten
Premierminister innerhalb kürzester Zeit
hat gerade ein gewaltiges
Rettungsprogramm für die Wirtschaft
angekündigt auch für Privatpersonen die
Inflation ist hoch Wirtschaftskrise
das Land sucht eine internationale
Position all das liegt heute auch in der
Luft
der Trauerzug zieht gerade
toll vorbei an den kriegerdenkmalen auch
wir sehen gleich noch mal den den
berühmten zenotafe das ist da ist er im
Bild dort findet alljährlich die
Feierlichkeit statt zum Gedenken an die
Opfer des ersten und des Zweiten
Weltkrieges und das ist auch eine der
großen Aufgaben des Monarchen dort den
Kranz niederzulegen und in den letzten
Jahren vor allen Dingen auch also im
vergangenen Jahr war Königin Elisabeth
II aufgrund wie es immer hieß von
mobilitätsproblemen nicht in der Lage
dazu und ließ sich dort vertreten und
hatte einen Statement gegeben übergeben
lassen und daran hieß es auch schon
nanofazit of time keiner von uns kann
die Zeit still halten und den Lauf der
Zeit festhalten es war eigentlich seit
dem Tod von Prinz Philip von ihrem Mann
vor anderthalb Jahren
sind die Königin immer weniger und man
sah sie bei den wenigen Auftritten dann
auch mit zunehmend schwindenden Kräften
strahlend hat sie sich zusammengerissen
der letzte große Auftritt bei den
Feierlichkeiten zum Platinum jubily zum
Platin Jubiläum im Juni diesen Sommer
aber wenn sie sich dann zu Wort meldete
häufig war es nicht mehr dann hat sie
die Nation beeindruckt vielleicht umso
mehr beeindruckt ich denke jetzt an ihre
Ansprache in der corona-zeit
auch wenn wir noch viel aushalten müssen
sollte uns die Gewissheit Trost spenden
das bessere Tage kommen werden dass wir
uns wieder mit unseren Freunden und
Familien treffen werden
dass wir mit Ihnen zusammen sein werden
dass wir wieder zusammenkommen werden
also
sie wusste schon den richtigen Ton zu
treffen um zu trösten sie war eine große
Trösterin
[Musik]
haben und gerade jetzt bei dem
platinjubiläum war wirklich noch mal
eine Szene sehr wurde auch oft gezeigt
und gesendet auch von uns wie sie wieder
mal ihren Humor unter Beweis gestellt
hat indem sie sich hat filmen lassen mit
Paddington Bär
der auch in einer Art von Schluss Geste
am Schluss den guthob und sagte danke
für alles
die britische times hat dieser Tage so
eine Statistik veröffentlicht die
wirklich beeindruckend ist
19.700 öffentliche Auftritte in der
70-jährigen Regentschaft
117 Länder besucht
300 7000 Glückwünsche zu hundertsten
Geburtstagen Versand
3,75 Millionen Briefe enthalten erhalten
14 US-Präsidenten erlebt 15
Premierminister viele Päpste
das ist ein Jahrhundert leben sie hat
alle prägenden Figuren der letzten
Jahrzehnte getroffen de Gaulle Mandela
Kennedy Gustav
Putin denkt sehr Ping natürlich
Brand Adenauer Merkel
und sie hatte so gern was sie gedacht
hat
bei Trump haben wir eine kleine Ahnung
da hat sie es geschafft eine Brosche zu
tragen die Obamas ihr geschenkt hatten
vorher es war ein ganz kleiner Hinweis
und er durfte nicht in der goldenen
Kutsche fahren anders als
der König hat auch ein wirklich sehr
sehr strammes Programm seitdem der König
ist
fährt überhaupt nicht auf er war bereits
in Schottland und in
Nordirland hat im britischen Parlament
gesprochen
verschiedene Gottesdienste absolviert
[Applaus]
und ist natürlich eigentlich auch ein
Trauernder Sohn
er war kein besonders beliebter
Thronfolger aber so würde ich die
Stimmung der letzten Tage zusammenfassen
er hat die Chance ein beliebter König zu
werden
und er hat ein paar treffende
Beschreibungen seiner Mutter geliefert
meine geliebte Mutter war eine Freundin
der Menschen eine Freundin der Wahrheit
eine Freundin der alten und eine
Leitfigur für die jungen
und er hat ein paar Mal
Shakespeare zitiert
um
klarzustellen wie einzigartig elisabeth
war
ein Vorbild für alle lebenden Prinzen
jetzt erreicht der Trauerzug
Westminster das eigentliche Ziel dieser
dieses trauerzugs
Bild dreht sich gerade der Big Ben das
Wahrzeichen von London anlässlich des
diamantennen thronjubiläums vor zehn
Jahren wurde der Big Ben umbenannt in
Elisabeth tower
in
Gedenken und in Verehrung für Königin
Elisabeth II
im Gefolge
der geschützler Fette mit dem Sarg der
Verstorbenen Königin die vier Kinder von
Königin Elisabeth der neue König Charles
Leben seine Schwester Prinzessin an
Prinz Andrew und Prinz Edward dahinter
noch mal einen Blick auf die Enkel der
Königin
Prinz William der Thronfolger Prinz
Harry und Peter Philipps der Sohn von
Prinzessin n
in der Westminster Hall wird jetzt eine
ein kleiner Gottesdienst stattfinden
eine
gedenkandacht wenn man so will
in dieses Gebäude wird
nun der Sarg
hinein gebracht werden
Westminster Hall der älteste Teil der
houses of Parlament
1797 erbaut im gotischen Stil ein
bemerkenswertes für diese Zeit
bemerkenswertes
säulenfreies heilunggebäude die größte
Halle Englands nicht Europas
noch mal einen Blick auf die imperious
state Crown die
krönungskrone der Königin die von ihrer
Urgroßmutter von Queen Victoria auch
stammt sie wurde entworfen damals für
die Krönung der legendären Queen
Victoria
also man kann das auch interpretieren
als ein Bekenntnis des Hauses Windsor zu
seiner konstitutionellen Rolle
ein Bekenntnis zur Demokratie dass
dieser Trauerzug sich jetzt in Richtung
Parlament bewegt
auch hier brandet Beifall auf
Prinz Charles hat in seiner Antwort auf
die Trauerreden im Ober- und Unterhaus
gesagt das Parlament ist das lebende und
atmende Instrument unserer Demokratie
als Zeichen des Respekts ziehen die
Sargträger sozusagen ihren Hut
der Sarg wird nun von der geschützler
fette gehoben
von Soldaten des ersten Bataillons der
grenady Guards ein Infanterie Regiment
ein Sack aus englischer Eiche wie wir
gelernt haben schon vor 30 Jahren
angefertigt und sehr schwer weil er mit
Blei ausgelegt ist inne
dieser Sarg wird am kommenden Montag
beigesetzt nach einer großen Trauerfeier
in der Westminster Abbey mit der Sarg
überführt nach Schloss Windsor wo er am
selben Tag zusammen mit dem Sarg von
Prinz Philip ihrem Ehemann
freigesetzt wird
es war ein Wunsch des Paares aufeinander
zu warten wer von beiden zuerst gehen
würde der würde so lange auf den anderen
warten und beide Särge werden
kommenden Montag in messen georgious
Chapo
in der Gruft der Familie von König
George dem sechsten beigesetzt
die Nachfahren von Königin Elisabeth II
folgen dem Sarg in den Palace of
Westminster
das Parlamentsgebäude
der britischen Demokratie
oder sagt
aufgebahrt wird für die nächsten vier
Tage
um den Menschen in Großbritannien und
auch über die Landesgrenzen hinaus die
Möglichkeit zu geben von Königin
Elisabeth der zweiten Abschied zu nehmen
andere Mitglieder der königlichen
Familie stehen Spalier auf der linken
sehen wir die Vettern der Queen Prinz
Michael von Kent den Herzog von Kent
und der erste Blick in die Westminster
Hall
wo normalerweise mittwochs reges Treiben
ist der mittwochs findet die Fragestunde
des Premierministers statt und dann
laufen dort Politiker in alle Richtungen
sich vorher abzusprechen
Vereinbarungen zu treffen wieder reden
zu organisieren ein Ort des politischen
Streits der natürlich heute
still steht um Platz gemacht hat
für die Krise
auf diesem Podest wird sie jetzt ruhen
in den nächsten vier Tagen
wenn diese kurze Zeremonie vorüber ist
wird dann die breite Öffentlichkeit die
Möglichkeit haben von ihr Abschied zu
nehmen
dieser feierliche Einzug
wird begleitet vom Chor der Westminster
Abbey
und von Chor ihrer Majestät
aus der chaper Royal
[Musik]
singt den Psalm 103
die Verse 1 bis 18
[Musik]
dieser Gottesdienst wird geleitet
vom Erzbischof von Canterbury Justin
wellby
den Primas der anglikanischen Kirche und
vom Dekan von Westminster
[Musik]
und Erlöser der Mensch
gemeinsam
und allen Verstorbenen Gläubigen das
Geschenk der Rettung und der ruhmreichen
Auferstehung
deines Sohnes
auf das wir am Ende aller Tage
in alle Dinge sich vereinen in Christus
mit ihnen in den Genuss all deiner
Verheißungen kommen mögen durch Jesus
Christus unseren Herrn
hebe die in Gott
belegt euer Herz nicht verunsichern
glaubt an Gott und glaubt an mich er
wird
im Haus meines Vaters sind viele wohnen
wenn nicht so hätte ich es euch gesagt
um euch eine Stätte zu bereiten und wenn
ich hingehe und euch eine Stätte bereite
so komme ich wieder und werde euch zu
mir nehmen damit auch ihr seid
wo ich bin
wohin ich aber gehe wisst ihr Thomas und
ihr kennt den Weg
lot
Thomas spricht zu ihm
wir wissen nicht wohin du gehst
und wie können wir den Weg
jesus spricht zu ihm
ich bin der Weg
und die Wahrheit das Leben
niemand kommt zum Vater als nur durch
mich
nach einem eröffnungsgebiet war das die
Lesung aus dem Johannesevangelium es
folgen weitere Gebete
gnädiger Gott Vater unseres Herrn Jesus
Christus der die Auferstehung und das
Leben
indem jeder Gläubige lebt und stirbt und
wer in ihm lebt und glaubt der stirbt
nicht ewig
Nordsee er hat uns durch seinen heiligen
Apostel Paulus gelehrt nicht traurig zu
sein nicht die Hoffnung zu verlieren
die in ihm ruhen flehen wir dich demütig
an Vater
erhebe uns vom sündentod in ein Leben in
Rechtschaffenheit auf das auch wir wenn
wir aus diesem Leben scheiden
so hoffen wir darauf dass dies auch
unsere Schwester zu Teil wird und dass
du uns am Tage der Auferstehung würdig
befindest
bewegen empfangen denn dein geliebter
Sohn allen verkünden wird die dich
lieben und fürchten
und er spricht
gesegnete Kinder meines Vaters
empfangt das Königreich das von Anbeginn
der Zeit für euch geschaffen
darum bitten wir dich gnädiger Vater
durch Jesus Christus unseren halsbringer
und Erlöser
sowie unser Retter Christus uns zu beten
gelehrt und befohlen hat rufen wir nun
vater unser im Himmel geheiligt werde
dein Name dann Reich komme dann Wille
geschehs wie im Himmel so auf Erden
unser tägliches Brot gib uns heute und
vergib uns unsere
Schuldigern
und führe uns nicht in Versuchung
sondern erlöse uns von dem Bösen
denn dein ist das Reich und die Kraft
und die Herrlichkeit in Ewigkeit Amen
bitte geleitet vom Dekan von Westminster
dr David heuer
[Musik]
Benutzer all Jena die auf dich Vertrauen
ohne den nichts stark und nichts heilig
ist
Meere und vervielfältige deine Gnade
über uns
damit wir mit dir als unserem Herrscher
und Wegweiser durch alles Weltliche
geleitet werden mögen
und das ewige Leben zu empfangen
darum bitten wir dich himmlischer Vater
um Jesus Christus Willen Amen
see and protection weekend in Gottes
Barmherzigkeit und seinen Schutz
übergeben wir dich der
Lotte dich
zeige dir sein Angesicht und erbarme
sich da
Wende dir sein Antlitz zu und schenke
dir
Gottes das Vaters des Sohnes und des
Heiligen Geistes
sei alle Zeit mit dir
ein kurzer Moment der Stille
in der Westminster Hall
wo der Sarg von Königin Elisabeth II
aufgebahrt ist
die königliche Familie nimmt Abschied
die Nachfahren von Königin Elisabeth II
von nun an ist der Leichnam der Königin
übergeben an
das Volk sozusagen die jetzt hier im
Herzstück der Demokratie dem britischen
Parlament Abschied nehmen können
noch am heutigen Tag werden die Pforten
so Westminster Hall für die
Öffentlichkeit geöffnet
wo rund um die Uhr
die Menschen
reingehen können um Abschied zu nehmen
von der Königin
in dieser Westminster Hall hat schon ein
sehr bewegender Moment im Rahmen dieser
Trauerfeierlichkeiten stattgefunden
als König Charles III vor wenigen Tagen
hier die
kondolenzbekundung der Parlamentarier
entgegengenommen hat
die Mitglieder beider Häuser des Ober-
und des Unterhauses hatten sich erhoben
von ihren Plätzen und die Hymne gesungen
Gott save the king
und damit auch den neuen König zu Tränen
gerührt
die einzelnen Regimenter aus der
Haushalt Division der Einheit der
britischen Streitkräfte die für den
Schutz der Königin und des Königs
zuständig ist
bezieht Position
um im Laufe der nächsten Tage
am Sarg zu wachen
auch im Protokoll vor Abschied
bevor dann
schon in wenigen Stunden
die hat Zutritt haben wird um der König
in ihr Respekt zu erweisen
ist natürlich Teil von Westen es ist
der parlamentarische teil und die ist
ein gewisser Weise Gast natürlich
der Hall ab und Charles den ersten der
wurde hier
Vorbild also insofern ist Ironie das
jetzt
natürlich hier seine Mutter
verabschiedet der Name Asien belastet ja
Westminster Hall ist natürlich der
Demokrat also
wir haben den eidkräften
wir sehen wir sind jetzt im Zeitalter
von König Charles dem dritten angekommen
mit seiner Frau Camilla und dem neuen
Thronfolgerpaar Prinz William und
Prinzessin Kate
sie verabschieden sich gerade vom Lord
Chamberlain das ist der Herzog von
Norfolk die Familie der Howards die den
dieses Herzogtum gehört es seid ja
hunderten für die den zeremoniellen Teil
von den Krönungen und den
Feierlichkeiten auch den trauerlich
Feierlichkeiten zuständig es ist ja
alles sehr
protokollarisch bis ins feinste Detail
geplant alles hier
der Herzog von Norfolk ist katholisch
also insofern weiß er sehr gut wie man
solche Sachen inszenieren kann ich
glaube hier kommt der
malve-farbene Rolls-Royce zum Einsatz
den wir vor 22 Jahren anlässlich des
hundertsten geburtstags von Queen Mum
auch gesehen
Zeit noch von seit der Zeit von Königin
Elbe Standarte und
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
wir
sehen hier noch einmal the mall wir
sehen hier noch einmal das Ende der
Trauerfeierlichkeiten für Queen
Elizabeth die zweite heute an diesem
Mittwoch
Königin Elisabeth II hat zum letzten Mal
Buckingham Palace verlassen
ihr Sohn König Charles III und die Enkel
Prinz William und Prinz Harry sind
zusammen
gemeinsam mit anderen
Familienmitgliedern zu Fuß hinter dem
Sarg zum Parlament gegangen
während Big Ben zu ihren Ehren
geschlagen hat
auf dem Sarg zu sehen waren die
königliche Standarte und die staatskrone
die Elisabeth zu ihrer Krönung vor 70
Jahren
getragen hat
im Minutentakt haben wir Salutschüsse
aus dem Hyde Park hören können auch wir
hier auf unserer Position im ZDF-Studio
in London konnten es hören
tausende Menschen haben stundenlang an
der Strecke gewartet viele Mobiltelefone
kamen zum Einsatz ein Moment den viele
Menschen nicht vergessen werden und auf
den sie auch sehr lange gewartet haben
wir haben schon am Montagabend
Menschen getroffen die campiert haben
hier vor dem Buckingham Palace um darauf
zu warten dass der Sarg an ihnen vorüber
zieht und das ist dann vor wenigen
Stunden geschehen sind Tränen gelaufen
als die Prozession vorbei gezogen ist
und
eine Eskorte von zwei Offizieren und 32
Soldaten des ersten Bataillons der
grenadiergarde in roten
universellen Mützen Schritt auf beiden
Seiten der Lafette hier hinter uns am
Set am jamesis Park können wir gerade
noch sehen die berittene Polizei
vorbeikommt denn es ist unglaublich viel
los in der Stadt tausende sind gekommen
um sich von ihrer Königin zu
verabschieden die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind sehr sehr
hoch wir sehen das Bild vom Buckingham
Palace und hier sehen wir
Westminster Hall wo schon bald sich die
Britinnen und Briten von ihrer Königin
selbst verabschieden können in einer
unglaublich langen Schlange harren sie
aus um einmal persönlich am Sarg vorbei
gehen zu können Abschied zu nehmen von
ihrer Königin es hat stark geregnet
letzte Nacht in London trotzdem
haben viele Menschen dort gewartet und
in Kürze wie gesagt werden sie sich dort
von ihrer Königin verabschieden können
und damit geben wir hier vom Studio
London wieder zurück
ans Kanada Gate zu Peter frei
ja
vielen Dank Christina von unseren
Sternberg die Familie ist mittlerweile
wieder angekommen im Buckingham Palace
und wir sehen in Westminster Hall
die Ehrenwache für Königin Elisabeth ist
aufgezogen in einer guten Stunde wird
dann auch das allgemeine Publikum die
Möglichkeit haben Abschied zu nehmen es
sind
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen getroffen worden
so wie man das von den Flughäfen kennt
man muss durch eine Sicherheitsschleuse
und
dann hat man die Möglichkeit Abschied zu
nehmen ein schlauer Kopf hat
ausgerechnet dass etwa 350.000 Menschen
durchgeschleust werden können bis
Montagmorgen wir werden sehen ob das
reicht oder ob es am Ende nicht noch
sehr viel mehr sind die hierher kommen
wollen
in Schottland haben wir gesehen dauerte
es die ganze Nacht und nur wer ganz früh
am Morgen erschienen ist hatte die
Chance ohne lange Warterei
vor dem Sarg der Queen zu stehen
der Sack ist geschmückt mit der Krone
auch die übrigen Insignien dieser
Herrschaft
werden ausgestellt werden
der Reichsapfel mit dem Kreuz als Symbol
einer weltumspannenden christlichen
Herrscherin ein Zepter aus gold
Diamanten geschmückt Insignien dieser
uralten britischen Monarchie
die hier investments the hall von einem
Zeitalter Abschied nimmt
70 Jahre
hat Elisabeth II ihre Nation
repräsentiert
durch viele Veränderungen geführt
aber sie war
schon durch ihre schiere Präsenz
durch ihre Verlässlichkeit
ein Anker in unruhigen und stürmischen
Zeiten
wir können noch mal unsere Runde machen
und auch mit den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die die letzten Stunden für uns
beobachtet haben draußen zusammen mit
dem Britinnen und Briten
zusammenfassen wie die Stimmung erlebt
wurde vielleicht beginnen wir mit Theo
call der direkt außerhalb von
Westminster Hall steht Theo du bist
lange
Korrespondent gewesen in London
hast die stürmischen Zeiten in den 90er
Jahren erlebt die Trauer um Diana den
Schock den das für das Königshaus
bedeutet hat wie war es heute für dich
das war ein grünender Abschluss eines
Kronen Lebens muss man sagen ich habe
diese Woche erlebt als Diana starb das
war eine Woche in der des Königreich in
Frage stand die Königin hat damals das
war wirklich eine schwierige Zeit sie
hat falsch reagiert sie hatte ein
schwieriges Verhältnis mit Diana und sie
ist nicht zurückgekommen nach London und
wurde im Grunde erst von damaligen
Premierminister Toni Blair dazu gebracht
und er hat sie dann entsprechend beraten
sie hatte eine Fernsehansprache gehalten
und das war ein Schlüsselmoment in
dieser Zeit sie hat danach auch sich
geöffnet die Monarchie wurde etwas
moderner aber das war ein Moment da
hätte Großbritannien hätte sie nicht
entsprechend reagiert sich
möglicherweise auch von der Monarchie
entschieden können und man sieht jetzt
25 Jahre später welche Kraft immer noch
die Monarchie hat aber natürlich auch
durch diese Frau also ich glaube dass es
jetzt eine ganz
offene Entwicklung ist
was schafft König Charles III an
Spannkraft an Klammer für dieses
Vereinigte Königreich zu leisten das vor
großen Problemen steht und man darf
nicht vergessen wir haben jetzt diese
opulenten Bilder gesehen diese Tradition
die Briten sind ja in traditionelles
Volk und gleichzeitig wird natürlich
auch deutlich wie sehr Königin Elisabeth
die Größe der Vergangenheit
transportiert hat immer noch ins Heute
die Bedeutung hat Großbritannien aber
nicht mehr
Königin Elisabeth als sie gekrönt wurde
als sie als die Königin wurde da gab es
Winston Churchill als Premierminister in
Deutschland Konrad Adenauer vakanzler
und den Russland Josef Stalin das war
die Zeit und jetzt all die Jahrzehnte
später ist Großbritannien ein anderes
Land viel weniger wichtig und die
Adaption des Landes unter einem neuen
König an diese Zeit ich glaube das wird
eine eine historische Aufgabe für den
neuen König
Theo ich muss den Moment unterbrechen
die Live-Bilder zeigen uns gerade die
neue Premierministerin listras und
sozusagen in seltener Eintracht mit ihr
auch
Kerst damals den Oppositionsführer von
der leberpartei hier ist die
Ministerpräsidentin von Schottland zu
sehen also die höchsten Repräsentanten
des Staates sind anwesend auch über die
parteikrenzen hinweg und das kann man
wohl auch sagen die Politik die
Parteipolitik ist in diesen letzten
Tagen zu einem Stillstand gekommen
trotz größter Auseinandersetzung die
hier geführt werden muss
um performen zu ermöglichen und
Großbritannien ähnlich wie viele andere
Länder vor dem wirtschaftlichen Kollaps
zu bewahren also Theo wenn sie noch mal
versuchen diesen politischen Moment auch
einzuordnen den Widerspruch den dieses
Land im Moment durchmachen muss zwischen
diesen außerordentlichen Feierlichkeiten
aber doch politisch gesehen einer
durchaus prekären Zeit
absolut ich glaube in kaum einem anderen
Land der Welt ist im Moment die
Diskrepanz so stark die Diskrepanz
zwischen dem was war was die Königin
auch repräsentiert hat was natürlich
auch durch die Traditionen hier immer
noch versucht wird zu bewahren all das
was wir sehen ist ja auch ein Zeichen
einer Außergewöhnlichkeit auch deswegen
schaut natürlich die ganze Welt auf
dieses Ereignis wir werden ja alle immer
gleicher und die Briten haben sich ihre
Außergewöhnlichkeit auch dadurch bewahrt
durch die Monarchie die ja nicht nur
eine Monarchie ist sondern sie hat ja
den Anspruch die Monarchie zu sein alle
anderen gelten ja eher als
fahrradmonarchien und ich glaube dass
das Land vor der Riesenaufgabe steht
diese mentale Lücke zu füllen und das zu
schaffen die Spanne zwischen dem wie man
sich selbst
bekommen hat welche Bedeutung man hatte
im Empire dann nachher reduziert im
Commonwealth und dann in die kleine
Realität eines vereinigten Königreichs
das mit inneren Spannungen zu tun hat
Sorge hat es die Schotten sich abtrennen
dass Nordirland in eine ganz schwierige
lagegerät durch
das die Positionierung auf der irischen
Insel die aber wiederum zu der
Europäischen Union gehört aus der
Großbritannien ausgetreten ist das wird
eine ganz schwierige Gemengelage wir
haben heute morgen gelesen dass die
Briten den Australier zum Beispiel ein
Dutzend Einladungskarten für Montag
gegeben haben die ja sehr sehr selektiv
nur ausgegeben wurden an Staats- und
Regierungschefs und ihre Ehepartner die
Australier haben aber ein Dutzend Karten
bekommen also da ist schon ein klares
Bewusstsein auch der Krise für das
Camembert dass man
diese Besonderheit zusammenzuhalten
und das spürt man natürlich das auch
diese Feierlichkeiten ein Stück Politik
sind
monarchische Politik aber auch
Realpolitik es geht um die Frage ob das
Königreich das von Elisabeth
repräsentiert und auch zusammengehalten
wurde einschließlich kommen wills auch
in den nächsten Jahren so weiter
bestehen wird war der bestehen kann oder
ob die Fliehkräfte immer noch größer
sind
während wir noch
investments to Hall verbleiben können
haben wir auch die Möglichkeit noch mal
darüber zu gehen zu meiner Kollegin Anne
Brühl Anne Winzer Castle wird ja dann
sozusagen der Schauplatz des nächsten
großen Tages sein des Zehnten Tages nach
dem Ableben der Queen dort wird sie am
kommenden Montag dann die letzte Ruhe
finden Anne Brühl
ja in Windsor war das hier tatsächlich
eher ein Tag der Vorbereitungen der
große Tag wird der Montag sein wenn die
Queen nämlich oder der Leichenwagen mit
dem Sarg der Queen hier in Winzer
ankommen wird
er wird den Weg nehmen durch den
longborg das ist ein Teil des Parks von
Winsor und das ist für die
Öffentlichkeit noch mal die letzte
Gelegenheit Abschied von der Queen zu
nehmen da werden zehntausende erwartet
dann wird es noch mal eine kleine eher
privatere Zeremonie in der
Schlosskapelle geben und dort wird die
Queen dann beigesetzt und das ist dann
tatsächlich ein Teil der ohne
Live-Kameras stattfinden wird sie wird
beigesetzt an der Seite ihrer Eltern
Prinz König George VI und seiner Frau
der späteren Queen mom auch die
Schwester des der Queen Prinzessin
Margaret ist dort beigesetzt und
auch ihr Mann Prinz Philip der in der
Krypta im Moment noch liegt dessen sagt
wird dort nach oben gebracht und so wird
die Queen dann ihre letzte Ruhe an der
Seite ihres Ehemanns finden
vielen Dank an der brüllen für diesen
Ausblick dann schon auf kommenden Montag
und wie die nächsten Tage dieser
Trauerfeierlichkeiten ablaufen werden
das können wir uns jetzt kurz anschauen
es sind die letzten Tage vor dem
Staatsbegräbnis um 18 Uhr deutscher Zeit
wird heute die Westminster Hall für alle
geöffnet der Sarg soll vier Tage lang
bis zum Morgen des staatsbegräbnisses
aufgebahrt werden
hunderttausende Menschen Staatsgäste
werden erwartet die von Queen Elizabeth
II Abschied nehmen und ihr die letzte
Ehre erweisen wollen am Montag um 7 Uhr
wird der Sarg vom Parlament zur
Westminster Abbey gebracht um 12 Uhr
beginnt die große Trauerfeier
nach dem Gottesdienst wird der Sarg zum
Triumphbogen Wellington Arch am Hyde
Park überführt mit dem königlichen
Leichenwagen geht es zur St George
Kapelle auf Schloss Windsor dort wird
die Königin neben ihrem Vater beigesetzt
und auch das können Sie meine Damen und
Herren im ZDF miterleben Kristina Ungarn
Sternberg hat in den letzten Stunden
genau beobachtet wie das Netz in dieser
neuen Öffentlichkeit mit dem heutigen
Tag umgegangen ist wie der Tag dort
gespiegelt wurde der Tod der Queen war
ein großes Ereignis in den sozialen
Medien in den letzten Tagen was ist
Ihnen dort heute aufgefallen Christina
also Peter frei mir ist tatsächlich
aufgefallen dass in den vergangenen
Stunden wo der sagte Queen hier durch
London gefahren wurde und sich über die
Stadt ihr habt es ja auch beschrieben so
eine Art Stille gesenkt hat dass das
auch ein bisschen im Netz zu spüren war
wir haben in unseren Kommentaren viel
Beileidsbekundungen viel abschiedsposts
bekommen ein paar kann ich mal vorlesen
über facebook hat eine Userin namens
Karin Scheel zum Beispiel geschrieben es
gehört einfach dazu dass man sich von
Queen Elizabeth live im Fernsehen
verabschieden kann sie wird auf ewig in
die Geschichte eingehen und das hat sie
auch verdient ich zitiere sie wird ihr
ganzes Leben ob es kurz oder lang dauern
wird für ihr Volk und ihrem lang Land
ein Leben lang dienen und das hat sie
auch getan deshalb hat sie auch meine
Hochachtung schreibt diese Userin
dann schreibt über Facebook Gottfried
Matthias rüberts in stiller Trauer sage
ich Danke an die Königin es ist
angemessen so Abschied zu nehmen noch
dazu wo sie es selbst mit geplant hatte
und es zeigt sich wie beliebt sie war
bis zum Schluss ein letzter Gruß
ja eindrucksvolle Zeugnisse und das wird
auch weitergehen in den sozialen Medien
auch auf der ZDF heute gibt es viele
Beiträge die wir gepostet haben und
natürlich haben Sie auch die Möglichkeit
darauf zu reagieren meine Damen und
Herren und dazu auch ihre eigenen
Empfindungen Sichtweisen vielleicht auch
Kritik festzuhalten vielen Dank
Christina von Ungarn sternberg
noch einmal einen Blick
Investment stop Hall die Herrschaften
die wir jetzt sehen repräsentieren im
Grunde schon die breitere Öffentlichkeit
die dann die Möglichkeit haben wird hier
vorbei zu definieren die Menschen werden
angehalten werden nicht zu verweilen vor
dem Sarg sondern sich zu bewegen damit
möglichst viele die Chance haben werden
Ihren persönlichen Abschied zu
vollziehen
vor allen Dingen die Mitarbeiter des
königlichen Haushalts die vielen
hunderte von Mitarbeitern die im Dienst
der Krone stehen die von vom vom
Management des Königshauses über die
Garderobe der Königin die Logistik die
für alles sorgen wir sehen auch noch
weitere Verwandtschaft der königlichen
Familie gerade die Frau von Prinz
Michael von Kent
Hofmarschall hofdamm
[Musik]
das gesamte Team des königlichen
Haushalts nimmt Abschied von seiner
Chefin
ja noch mal die Spitzen der britischen
Politik die an der Zimmermann auch als
politische Beobachterin die würden sie
das Einordnen was wir heute gesehen
haben
Herr Frieda im Friede im Parlament
natürlich die alle nehmen Abschied von
ihrer Queen es heißt die Regierung ihrer
Majestät und die Opposition ihrer
Majestät so bezeichnen sich die wieder
streitenden Parteien im Parlament es
gibt wirklich aus allen Parteien
Beileidsbekundungen aus manchen ein
bisschen weniger er biete ich als aus
den anderen der grüne Vorsitzende Harvey
aus Schottland etwa hat an den Prinzen
eine Rede gehalten die ein bisschen so
klang als müsste er sich wirklich sehr
zusammenreißen damit er die
Unterstützung
weiter behalten können da sind schon
durchaus verschiedenen Nuancen drin und
wie Theorie sagte wird es ein wirklich
schwieriger Weg den der neue König zu
beschreiten hat
ich glaube dass diese Spannung die
zwischen den Königshaus und der
Realpolitik liegt im Grunde genommen
unter ihm geringer sein wird denn er ist
ja sehr viel mehr im wahrhaftigen Leben
verankert als die Krise war aber den
Glanz aufrecht zu erhalten und
gleichzeitig nicht völlig veraltet zu
wirken das wird eine wirklich schwierige
Aufgabe sein jedenfalls war der heutige
Tag ein Tag des Innehaltens und einer
ein Tag einer Einheit wie in
Großbritannien auch lange nicht erlebt
hat in seiner aufgehitzten polarisierten
Stimmungslage der letzten Jahre
ja das stimmt und für die
Premierministerin ist es natürlich eine
extrem ungewöhnliche erste Woche sie hat
sich sehr geschickt bisher einfach
zurückgehalten alles andere wäre wohl
auch viel am Platze gewesen
der Sarg von Elisabeth der zweiten
bedeckt von der Krone ihres Reiches und
einem einfachen Kranz ihre
Lieblingsblumen wie man hat lesen können
London hat heute Nachmittag still
gestanden Blick auf die Themse links der
Komplex der houses of Parlament zu dem
die Westminster Hall auch gehört
links davon liegt dann Westminster Abbey
wo am Montag dann die offiziellen
Feierlichkeiten stattfinden werden zudem
Dutzende von Staatsoberhäuptern aus
aller Welt erwartet werden und wir sehen
hier schon die Lampe Bridge wo sehr
viele Menschen jetzt sich bewegen dürfen
also diejenigen die die Nacht über
gewartet haben können jetzt Vorrücken
auf die andere Seite der Themse um sich
noch einmal zu verneigen vor ihrem
Staatsoberhaupt
meine Damen und Herren eine
vierstündige Übertragung geht zu Ende
fünf Tage nach dem Tod von Queen
Elizabeth hat London hat die britische
Hauptstadt begonnen Abschied zu nehmen
von der Queen auch ihre Familie hat sich
von ihr verabschiedet es war ein Tag in
einer
eindrucksvollen Mischung von Dankbarkeit
Trauer Respekt Konzentration und am Ende
auch Einheit und trotzdem war es ein Tag
der auch die Herausforderung gezeigt hat
der auf die königliche Familie auf
Charles den dritten und seine Frau
Camilla jetzt zukommt
wir bedanken uns für Ihr Interesse und
ich habe sie im Laufe dieser Sendung mit
vielen Zitaten zu diesem
unglaublichen jahrhundert leben von
Queen Elizabeth der zweiten versorgt ich
habe noch eins am Ende gefunden dass mir
besser als jedes andere zu verdeutlichen
scheint was wir heute hier erlebt haben
es kommt von dem britischen Historiker
Timothy Garden Aesch und er schreibt es
wird niemals mehr in der Geschichte
einen anders geben zu dem eine andere
britische Persönlichkeit weltweit so
betrauert wird in gewisser Weise ist es
der letzte Moment britischer
Großartigkeit
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse wir
bedanken uns dafür aus London
[Musik]